OKAY LET'S CALL THIS
HEARINGOF THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY COMMITTEE
TO ORDER. NOW WE ARE STILL IN
THE CODE RED EMERGENCY AND-
WE'RE ALLOWING PEOPLE BECAUSE
MORE FOLKS ARE NOT SHOWING UP
IN PERSON- BUT PEOPLE STILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CALL
IN. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS 877-692-8953 THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX NINE
ZERO NINE. WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC
COMING TO BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION. RESTOS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
SIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RESERVE YOUR- LINE NUMBER A
PLEASE WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MATTER TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER THEN YOU'LL BE ON YOUR
TV OTHER. ADDRESSED THE
COMMITTEE. ABOUT NINE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA TO BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE DON'T YET
HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE CAN GET
STARTED. AS A SUB COMMITTEE-
WITH THE TWO MEMBERS HERE SO
WHEN WE START WITH YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI ONCE
WE HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISHED
WILL LA PAZ TO. ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BUT WE'LL START WITH AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER CITIES CLIMB
A CRISIS ACTOR. YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THIS IS A CHAIRMAN AND-
GOOD MORNING SENATORS. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE THE CALIFORNIA COURT
CLAIMING CRISIS ACT. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY CLARIFYING AND
ACCEPTING ALL OF THE- IN MEN'S
INDICATED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SO I WANT TO THANK.
THE YOUR COMMITTED STAFF AS
CHAIRMAN FOR. THEIR HARD WORK
ON THIS VERY THOROUGH VERY
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT- NATIONALLY AND
GLOBALLY. SO I KNOW THAT THIS
COMMITTEE. DOES NOT TO. NEED TO
BE TOLD THAT THE CLIMATE CRISIS
IS HERE AND NOW WE JUST CAME
OUT OF THIS WEEKEND WITH RECORD
EXTREME HEAT. WE SEE THE
CONTINUING EFFECTS OF THE
DROUGHT. WILDFIRES BLAZING
DECADES AHEAD OF WHAT
SCIENTISTS HAD ORIGINALLY%
SCHEDULED IN TERMS OF ITS
SEVERITY. AND SO IT'S CLEAR
THAT WE CANNOT GO ON WITH
BUSINESS AS USUAL. AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. SIXTY ACCOMPLISH
THREE MAIN OBJECTIVES FIRST TO
REQUIRE THE STATE. TO ACHIEVE
NET ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
OR NO LATER THAN TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AND TO ACHIEVE AND
MAINTAIN NET NEGATIVE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THEREAFTER THAT'S ONE. SECOND
THIS BILL ALSO WOULD REQUIRE
THAT 90% OF OUR STATE'S HUMAN
CAUSED EMISSIONS ARE ELIMINATED
THROUGH DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. AND THIRD THIS BILL
PRESCRIBES CRITERIA AND
SAFEGUARDS FOR THE USE OF
CARBON CAPTURE STORAGE. CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES. THIS BILL HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED
THROUGH THE COURSE OF GETTING
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY AND NOW IN
THIS COMMITTEE AGAIN THE SENATE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS-
DEFINITELY HELP CLARIFY AND
IMPROVE THIS BILL AND SO WE
APPRECIATE THE MAN WAS VERY
MUCH BUT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT TO. THE AMENDMENTS. A MAKE
IT ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT CAP CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE OR ANY
OTHER CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL
THE TECHNOLOGIES AND ANYWAY.
HOWEVER I AM COULD I AM AWARE
THAT TO. THE OPPOSITION-
CONTINUES TO RAISE CONCERNS. ON
THESE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
AND SO I'M COMMITTEDTO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM I
WITH THAT SO I WOULD LIKE TO.
KALAPANA TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- WE HAVE
A- NO WITNESSES FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND. AND
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
INTERESTING ALL RIGHT LET'S
START WITH YOUR FIRST WITNESS-
CAITLYN ROHNER FROM THE VERMONT
DEFENSEMAN. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU SCHERING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND CAITLIN RUNNERS
BETTER SENIOR MANAGER FOR U. S.
CLIMATE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE. THE CLIMATE CRISIS FACT.
YOU HEARD THE GOAL ALREADY- AND
AS A DESCRIBING YOUR SPELLING
AND THESE ARE IN LINE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL ON
CLIMATE CHANGE THE BACK
SCIENTIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ACHIEVE. CARBON NEUTRALITY OR
NET ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BY NO LATER THAN
TWENTY FORTY FIVE- CRITICALLY
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES 90%
EMISSION REDUCTION BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE ENSURING THAT WE ARE
DOUBLING DOWN ON EMISSIONS
REDUCTION. TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO.
I THIS BILL DOES NOT PLACE.
RESTRICTION ON THE USE OF
STRATEGIES LIKE CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE AND IT RECOGNIZES
THAT MASON CARBON REMOVAL
TECHNOLOGIES WILL BE IMPORTANT
TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO AN
ESSENTIAL TO ACHIEVING THAT
NEGATIVE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS- BUT- RESPECTED IT
ALSO CRITICAL TO SET STRICT.
STANDARDS FOR THE YOU CAN BE
STRATEGIES TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
AIR QUALITY IS NOT HARMED IT
STORED CARBON THANK THE WITH
INTEGRITY AND THAT COMMUNITIES
ECOSYSTEMS AND GROUNDWATER ARE
PROTECTED THIS IS REALLY AN.
ESSENTIAL PART OF EACH THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. I DECLINE CRISIS
IN URGENTLY NEEDED HEALTHCARE
DOES NOT HAVE ANY. WIDE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
STATUTES AFTER TWENTY THIRTY
BUT WE NEED TO BE WORKING NOW
TOWARD NET NEGATIVE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. MAXIMIZING
REDUCTION IN THIS DECADE MEANS
GREATER CUMULATIVE REDUCTION
WHICH IS NECESSARY CAN MEET OUR
NEW COUNTRY GOAL. MANY OF THOSE
REDUCTION STRATEGIES CAN BE
DEPLOYED OR ENHANCED RIGHT NOW
WITH TECHNOLOGY WE ALREADY OUT-
AND YOUR RESOURCES BOARD AND IS
LOOKING AT ALL OF THIS RIGHT
NOW IS THE BEGIN THERE STILL BE
PLAN UPDATE. TIMELY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE THEIR
DIRECTION I THOUGHT I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT AND AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. THE YOU I WAS
MOUNT GO TO MICHELLE PASSARO
FROM THE CONCERNED. BEING OUT
OF THE SHELL CASTRO DIRECTOR OF
THE CLINIC PROGRAM FOR THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY I THANK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE CHANCE TO SPEAK ALTHOUGH
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. EIGHTEEN
GARCIA FOR THEIR ONGOING
LEADERSHIP CONTRACT CLIMATE
CHANGE- I'LL ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND- I
JUST RECOGNIZE THE MEMBER ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING ON A REGULAR BASIS
THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
IF WE DON'T XCELERATED SEPARATE
EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES
IN THE ATMOSPHERE OUR EFFORTS
TO ADAPT AND BE MORE RESILIENT
ARE ONLY GOING TO GET HARDER-
IPTC. AS CAITLYN ALREADY
MENTIONED- SAID THAT IN ORDER
FOR US TO AVOID THE WORST AND
MOST DEVASTATING IMPACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE HAVE TO
EXPLORERS. AND BE CARBON
NEUTRAL NO LATER THAN MID
CENTURY IF NOT SOONER THAN AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE BUT THE
FRONT PATH. TO HELP ACHIEVE BUT
YOUR CALL BY ACCELERATING THE
DEMAND EMISSION REDUCTIONS THAT
90% THRESHOLD WHICH CAN INCLUDE
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE. AND
BY ELEVATING OTHER CRITICAL
CRITICAL CLIMATE STRATEGIES
LIKE NATURE BASED CLIMATE
POLLUTION. SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS
CONDUCTED BY MY COLLEAGUES AT
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
OTHER COLLEAGUES. INDICATE THAT
WITHOUT ACTIVE INTERVENTION AND
IMMEDIATE INTERVENTION OUR
NATIONAL WORKING LANDS AT RISK
OF BECOMING INCREASING THAT
REST OF THE NATION. SOMEWHERE
WHERE AT TIMES IF YOU COULD
JUST WRAP UP YOUR POINT WHERE
YOU WERE BECAUSE WE'RE GIVING
EQUAL TIME TO EACH TO BOTH
SIDES AND YOUR PREVIOUS.
WITNESS SAYS. SPOKEO LONGER. AT
OKAY I WELL ANYWAY BILL HELP
WITH THAT SO AND EXPAND OUR
ACTION WITH THE CASE GALA YEAH
YOU WE WERE- DR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY LET'S
NOW HEAR FROM PEOPLE WHO LIKE
TO WIN INSTEAD OF THE BILL. AND
THEN DOES HE WANT. IN PER- IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
MATTER WHO'D LIKE TO WIN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WHY NUMBER ONE
OKAY. THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT GIVE. MY
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER NUMBERS
NIKITA KARATE WITH ENERGY C. IN
STRONG SUPPORT HAVE ALSO BEEN
AFTER REGISTER. THE LINE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY I'M
IN OPPOSITION. NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS A LEASE CONTRACT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BLIND NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS-
DR- JIM STEWART YEAH. AND THIS
IS I AM GREATLY AT SUPPORT OF
THIS GOAL FOR IT GUYS. MY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE LINE NUMBER TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JENNIFER CONNIE AND
I'M A THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS MEGAN CHOATE.
IT REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO
THREE FIFTY STROKES RECORDED AB.
THREE I THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. GREAT I
KNOW WE'VE GOT- VERY SPECIAL-
SUPPORTER HERE TAKE A MORE
CITIES HERE- ANDERSON RACER-
LOS THOSE WANTS TO ADD HER
VOICE OF SUPPORT FOR HER DAD'S
BILL SO WELCOME. OKAY LET'S GO
NOW TO OPPOSITION AND- WERE
FIRST CAME HERE I GUESS WE GOT.
THREE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
OKAY SO WE'LL START WITH- BUT
BEFORE WE DO THAT LET'S A
SUBSEQUENT. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HERE ALLEN
HERE BATES HERE BATES HERE
DALLI DALLI HERE GONZALEZ
SKINNER STERN BY CASCADE HERE
HERE. ALL RIGHT FOR DOESN'T
HAVE A QUORUM- SO LET'S LET'S A
LET'S START WITH YOU SO WHAT
WE'LL START WITH THEM WE ALSO
WITH THEIR AND FROM THE
CONFERENCE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
NEVER GONNA HEAR FROM TIM
JEFFRIES AND LANCY HASTINGS.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEAH SILVERTHORNE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE BUT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
OF NOT LIMITING THE USE OF
CARBON CAPTURE SEQUESTRATION IN
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
WE DO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE NOT FOR CLOSING OR
DETERRING INVESTORS FROM
INVESTING IN THIS TECHNOLOGY.
OR ANY PARTICULAR A FUTURE
TECHNOLOGY AND I RESPECTFULLY
WHERE I THINK AT A DIFFERENCE
OF OPINION WITH RESPECT TO HOW
THE BILL IMPACTS THE MARKET SO
I JUST WANNA READ A RECENT A
QUOTE FROM A RECENT REPORT BY
THE PRESIDENT'S COUNCIL ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY WHICH WAS
RELEASED AT THE END OF JUNE AND
I GOAL THAT SAYS TO REACH THE
PRESIDENT'S AMBITIOUS DOMESTIC
CLIMATE GOAL OF NET ZERO
EMISSIONS ECONOMY WIDE BY
TWENTY FIFTY. THE UNITED STATES
WILL LIKELY HAVE TO CAPTURE
TRANSPORT IMPROPERLY SEQUESTER
SIGNIFICANT QUANTITIES OF CO
TWO IN ADDITION THERE IS
GROWING SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS
THAT CARBON CAPTURE UTILIZATION
SEQUESTRATION AND CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL WILL LIKELY
PLAY A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
DECARBONIZATION EFFORTS
GLOBALLY ACTION IN THE UNITED
STATES CAN DRIVE DOWN
TECHNOLOGY CLUB COSTS
ACCELERATING CCS DEPLOYMENT
AROUND THE WORLD SO AS WE MOVE
FOR WITH THIS BILL WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT SENDING THE WRONG
SIGNAL TO- THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY INVESTORS TO WOULD
NOT INVEST IN THAT TECHNOLOGY
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU OKAY WHAT'S NEXT YEAR FROM
TONY JEFFRIES FROM- THE. THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS. ONE SHARES ALLEN.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENT QUALITY. ITEMS
TO THE JEFFRIES ON THE BUSINESS
MEDICAL MUCH OF A LOT FIVE FOUR
NINE LOCATED PITTSBURG
CALIFORNIA. PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
SEE CARBON CAPTURE INNOVATION
KILLING CALIFORNIA FOCUS ONLY
ON KILLING FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY. THAT EMPLOYS HUNDREDS
IF NOT THOUSANDS CALIFORNIANS
THAT WE HAVE THEM BUT WE HAVE
WHAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON IT IS
THE AFFECTS OF THIS MISGUIDED
POLICY WILL HAVE ON THE
INNOVATIVE AND- INNOVATIVE
MANUFACTURING SIGNS IN THE
STATE. GOOD TO MEET STATE CROC
CLIMATE CRISIS. CALIFORNIA
LEADER MANUFACTURING CARS AND
ELECTRIC CARS AND BUSES. THEY
DISPOSITIVO DON'T WANT A JOB IN
MANUFACTURING OR FOR THAT
MATTER IS BORN OF MAKERS I CAN
TELL YOU FROM THE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE EVERY A PRINCETON
WALKS INTO OUR TRAINING
FACILITY DOES. HAS PROVIDED A
PATHWAY TO THE MIDDLE CLASS TO
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES. AND
ARE PROUD TO BE AT THE PUMP
BEEN PROUD TO BE A PART OF
BUILDING TRADE CENTER POLL 32%
OF THE SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND. MEMBERS THAT COME
THROUGH. WE HAVE A PRETTY FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR MANY THEM FROM
THE ARMED FORCES JUST LIKE MY-
MANY OF THEM FOR THE CURRENT
JUST. AND FALL **** WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THIS COMMITTEE
SEES BE. THIS WHAT IS POSSIBLE
IS THAT CALIFORNIA. WE SHOULD
BE THE LEADER IN THE
INNOVATION. AND CARBON CAPTURE
TECHNOLOGY AND RENEWABLE FUELS
ENERGY AND IN A MATTER OF FACT
IT NEEDS TO MEET THE GOALS
CAUGHT. ON A CRISIS. AVAILABLE
MAKERS I RESPECTFULLY. ASK THAT
YOU OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
YOU ARE LET'S GO AN ECELLENT
TASTINGS FROM C. M. TA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER SOME TESTIMONY TODAY. SIR
ABOUT THE BILL BECAUSE IT'S
CHANGING THE RULES WHILE WE'RE
PLAYING THE GAME AND OUR
EMISSIONS GOALS TARGETS A
RATHER AGGRESSIVE. WE'RE
PARTICIPATING IN SEVERAL
STUDIES RIGHT NOW TO SHOW THIS
CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT EVEN TO
MEET EXISTING MANDATE. TO BRING
THOSE FORWARD IS EVEN MORE
DEVASTATING TO THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR WHICH IS
CRITICAL AS YOU KNOW TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AS WELL AS THE
NATION'S ECONOMY. ON BEHALF OF
ALL OF THE BUSINESS GROUPS THAT
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR- NO
VOTE TODAY- IN CERTAINLY- IN
THE COURSE OF THE ACTIVITY
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS.
OF MOVING THESE MANDATES
FORWARD AS WE GO BECAUSE IS
JUST A LACK OF ATTENTION TO
WHAT THE IMPACT MIGHT BE ON.
ALL OF THE INDUSTRY SECTORS
BUT- SPECIFICALLY ON%
MANUFACTURING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU OKAY LET'S OPEN THE PHONE
LINES ARE FOR FOLKS WHO WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OR EXPRESS OPPOSITION. OH I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY. HERE WE GO. I
BY THE WAY I YOU KNOW ONCE
AGAIN THAT LINES ARE GETTING
REALLY JAMMED- SAYS A LOT OF
SUPPORT THAT I UNDERSTAND
TRYING TO CALL IN BUT- YOU
KNOW. THIS IS A IN PERFECT
SYSTEM- HERE FROM LET'S HEAR
FROM FOLKS WHO ARE HERE PERCENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOU'RE A
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
STILL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MONAHAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL. AND
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARKET PARKS
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT CRIMMINS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS HERE TODAY
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
RESENJA MEREDITH ON BEHALF OF
NORTH STATE BUILDS IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU.
LET'S NEXT HEAR FROM THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPOSITION OF
AB. THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW.
BY NUMBER FORTY SEVEN THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS CHERYL FONG AND I'M
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION OFTEN ISN'T
AS BAD ANALYZED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND ORGANIZATIONS THAT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND WE
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE OH ONE
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND IT IS ALSO THE SMART
SHEET METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE
ZERO FIVE THANK THE BUILDING
TRADES- IN OPPOSITION. MY
NUMBER ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BOB
HERTZBERG PAPERS ABOUT LIGHT
TRADE DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY
SIX IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE OH FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JAMES THROW ACTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
LABORS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
I DON'T IN ANY COMPANIES
MANAGING WAS A COMMERCE
REPRESENTING AS WELL ARE OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE LOCAL
HISPANIC CHAMBERS DISSOCIATION
IN STRONG STRONG OPPOSITION. BY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA FUELS AND
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION. LINE NUMBER THIRTY
ONE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING GLENDALE
BALL WITH IRONWORKERS UNION
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT-
BEING WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AND ITS AFFILIATES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MAGGIE MUNSON WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH CHAMBER ANYTHING
IN G. A. IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. WHY NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
MAY BE ALIGNED MUTE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YEAH. YES GOOD MORNING
JOHANNA ROCK WITH THE HUMBOLDT
DEL NORD BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION. TRADES WE STAND
IN OPPOSITION- WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
ON THE THURMOND AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE MALONE BUT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA OUT THAT
AMERICANS NAME WILL CONVERT.
ALL WHO REPRESENTED THE BLOOD
BUSINESS BOTH IN CALIFORNIA
PHONE NUMBER CRAFTED WERE
CRAWLING UP TO THE END OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE THANK YOU.
WHY NUMBER FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS RON HUNT I WORK FOR CHEVRON
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. ONE
THREE NINE FIVE. MY NUMBER ONE
OH THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
CONTROL AND CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
COMPETITION AB THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. BLIND NUMBER SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS YELEY JOBURG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN OPPOSITION. LINE
NUMBER FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING BRIAN HOLD WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND KERN
COUNTY AND WE'RE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO DISPEL. WHY NUMBER NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LIE NUMBER NINETY SIX
MAYBE REMIND THEM YOU YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TOM WOMEN WITH THE SAN
DIEGO BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL CALLING IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE ADDED ON BEHALF
OF THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE WORK WITH THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE AND HOPE TO GET
TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN NOT
GOING TO TRONG ó BAO. THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS RAY ROSSITER
COUPLE SIXTEEN PAINTERS ALLY
TRADING WE STATUS THE BILLING
TRADE MISSION AB THIRTEEN NINE
THANK. BY NUMBER FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS-
JOHN PRINTER I WOULD FOR
CHEVRON AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
RANDY WIMMER IRONWORKERS LOCAL
FOUR SIXTEEN. WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF. AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. WHY
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KATRINA ONCE
OF TWENTY FINING COMPANY AND
AYE OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
ONE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARK BOB
FROM IBEW LOCAL FIVE NINE FIVE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. ONE
NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS STEVE ALONG
WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF AB. THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. MY
NUMBER FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JUST PLAIN A
LAFAYETTE THE TWENTY FINING
COMPANY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING. BY NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS WILLIAM GONZALEZ
WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU. ONE NUMBER FORTY THREE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAYBE YOUR LINES AND YOU LINE
NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MY NUMBER FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE NUMBER FIFTY TWO
MAY BE ALIGNED THE MUTE. HELLO
THIS IS KIRTI POLO WITH THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. WHY
NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HM
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JULIA ROMERO
I WERE FOR CHEVRON WILL PRESENT
A FATHER OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
NEW TO LOCALS WITH THE PHONE
AND CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL
OF LABORERS COLLEAGUES TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JESSE THING
WITH OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
THREE. WE'RE JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION. TO AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
THIS IS A GARCIA WHAT WILL MAKE
HER LOCAL NINE TWO AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN MAY
BE ON YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HI MY NAME IS RANDALL THERE ARE
WHAT DISTRICT OUT SIXTEEN
BATTERS OUR TRADE WE STAND WITH
THE BILL THE TRADE OPPOSITION
THE BABY THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. ONE NUMBER FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JEFFREY
ROBERTS WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES WE
STAND IN OPPOSITION TO THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES AT.
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. MY NUMBER
ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ROMAN FREER
WITH LABOUR'S INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF NORTH AMERICA PACIFIC
SOUTHWEST REGION ON BEHALF OF
OUR EIGHTY THOUSAND MEMBERS WE
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT MIKE PRATT
BUT TEAMSTER LOCAL FOR THIRTY
ONE FRESNO I CAME TO THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BEING ONE THREE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING MY
NAME IS VIVEK BROWN PREGGO THE
IRON WORKERS OR THIRTY EIGHT
BACK STREET OPPOSITION AB RIGHT
BACK THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WANT HIM FOR A
SECOND BREXIT OF THE SACRAMENTS
HERE AS BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
CLOSING THE NINETY FIVE ALONG
WITH THE STATE OF ISRAEL THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DON'T USE THEM. MY NAME IS
GENERALLY ONLY CHEVRON AND I
OPPOSE AB. THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE. REVERT THE GENERAL NUMBER
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARK DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
LEADERS LOCAL SIXTEEN WE STAND
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. Y. NUMBER THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JASON
WITHOUT- WITH INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL FIVE FIVE AND WE
JOINED STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL OF
OUR MONEY NICKEL METAL I WORK
FOR AN WORKERS LOCAL EIGHTEEN
WE AND ON OPPOSITION OF. ONE
FIVE WITH THE PUBLIC. THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR ISRAEL
SALAS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAPS IN OPPOSITION.
LIE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DOUG MORNING
WITH LABOR LOCAL THREE TWENTY
FOUR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING RON MILLER EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE LA ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES ON
BEHALF OF A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN THOUSANDS THAT GET UP
EVERY MORNING AND WORK TOWARDS
CLIMATE. GOALS WE RESPECTIVELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL DUE TO THE-
DISINGENUOUS LANGUAGE. BY NOT
COUNTING CARBON CAPTURE THAT
WOULD HAPPEN IN THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY THANK YOU. LIE NUMBER
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS KELLY
GAMRAT WITH CHEVRON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. BLIND NUMBER
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HONOREE KALYA WITH
PTSD BAND AND A CONCERNED
CITIZEN AND I OPPOSE AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. MY NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS JOHN
HENRY LOPEZ WITH THE UNITED
ASSOCIATION LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS
REPRESENTING FRESNO MADERA
TULARE KINGS AND WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM SO
SORRY WE'RE NOW IN FIFTEEN
MINUTES THIS IS OUR- CUT OFF.
AND SO I BELIEVE WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE AND WE'VE GOT A LIST
OF OPPOSITION. GROUPS THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION SO WE WENT
WE NOTE THAT WAS GONNA TAKE
NOTE OF THE VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION IT'S ON PAGES
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN. OF OF
YOUR OF YOUR NOW SEES MEMBERS
AND THAT SUPPORT IS ON FIFTEEN
AND SIXTEEN SO. PLEASE TAKE A
LOOK- IF PEOPLE WANT TO SUBMIT
ADDITIONAL WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE OR TO THE AUTHOR.
WITH THEIR MOST WELCOME- BUT WE
HAVE A LONG AGENDA TODAY AND
WE'VE GOT A CUT OFF SO
APPRECIATE EVERYONE CALLING IN.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING THE ITEM
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR
DISCUSSION QUESTIONS WILL START
WITH US CHAIR EMERITUS. SARAH
CASKEY THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
I'M ON MY PAGE THIRTEEN AND THE
THIRTEEN IN THE FOURTEEN AYE
AYE UNFORTUNATELY I WAS NOT
VISITED BY ANYBODY IN ORGANIZED
LABOR ON THIS BILL THOUGH I'VE
HEARD A LOT OF OBJECTIONS TO
THE BILL AND IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
NOBODY IDENTIFIED THAT THERE IS
LANGUAGE THAT AFFECTS CARBON
CAPTURE BECAUSE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. I THINK
SINCE WE ONLY PRODUCE 1% OF THE
GREENHOUSE GASES THE GIFT THAT
CALIFORNIA CANGIVE TO PEOPLE
IS EXPORTING OUR TECHNOLOGY.
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR ELEVEN YEARS
I'VE SAID FOR ELEVEN YEARS ALL
SAY FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS IS
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO PUT A
CLAMP ON THE TECHNOLOGY- BUT
I'LL GET TO SOME OF THE OTHER
STUFF SO I'M READING THAT THE
LAST BULLET SAYS REQUIRE THE-
AIRPORT TO IDENTIFY A VARIETY
OF POLICIES. AND STRATEGIES
THAT SUPPORT COPPER CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL SOLUTIONS AND
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
TECHNOLOGIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
COMPLEMENT EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
NATURE BASED CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
AND ACHIEVE DURABLE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTIONS OR
CARBON RENEWABLES AND IT GOES
ON TO THE NEXT ONE. SEE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL THE
LANGUAGE THAT YOU HAVE BECAUSE
I HAVEN'T SEEN A MARKUPS SO.
I'M FLYING HERE. IS IT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHAT'S IN
THE BILL RIGHT NOW IS REMOVED
AND THIS IS PUT IN. THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY. A BOMB. THIS
LANGUAGE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
STAFF AMENDMENTS- PROPOSED BY
THIS COMMITTEE. MAKES IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR AND IT SHOULD
BE SENDING A CLEAR MARKET
SIGNAL TO ANY OF THE INVESTORS
THAT TO. THE- THE CALCHAMBER- I
HAD REFERRED TO EARLIER- THAT
WE WANT. TO INCENTIVIZE THE
INNOVATION AND CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE WE WANT. THE
INNOVATION AND THE CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL AND- THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IN THIS
BILL. TO DIS INCENTIVIZE THE
INVESTMENTS THE INNOVATION IN
FACT THIS LANGUAGE MAKES IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR. THAT WE ARE
IN FULLY IN SUPPORT WE ARE
MANDATING. TO THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO COME UP WITH POLICIES
AND STRATEGIES TO SUPPORT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES. RIGHT I'M I KNOW
THAT MANY OF YOUR SUPPORTERS
BECAUSE I'VE TALKED WITH THEM-
WOULD CRINGE AT THE BIG
KNOWLEDGE MAN OF INCINERATION
OF OUR WASTE BUT NOW WE IN THE
URBAN AREAS IN THE SUBURBAN
AREAS LOVE TO LOAD UP OUR WAY
SINCE HAVE THE TEAMSTERS GET IN
THEIR TRUCKS AND DRIVER THREE
HUNDRED MILES AWAY. TO DISPOSE
OF IT BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND WE KNOW
THAT THE REST OF THE WORLD
INCINERATES AND DOES CARBON
CAPTURE AND HAS A ZERO NET
IMPACT IN ISN'T. RUNNING
RUINING OUR ROAD SERVICE-
STRESSING OUT OUR ROADS WITH
WITH LOADS AND LOADS OF OUR
GARBAGE SO- I WOULD THINK IN
THAT SPIRIT THAT THAT WOULD BE
THE TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY THAT WE
WOULD HOPE TO DEVELOP THAT ONE
DAY WE ALL BREATHE EASIER
ABOUT. USING TECHNOLOGY TO
REDUCE OUR CARBON CAPTURE- I
THINK THIS ENOUGH MISTER. OKAY
YES CENTER STERN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND- YOUR DURABILITY
AND PUSHING FORWARD FOR YEARS
NOW IN INSISTING ON. SOMETHING
MORE THAN WHAT WE'VE GOT ON THE
BOOKS RIGHT NOW WHEN IT COMES
TO CLIMATE I THINK THAT RESTING
ON OUR LAURELS THAT WHILE THE
WHOLE STATES ON FIRE AND HEAT
IS A HUNDRED TWENTY DEGREES IN.
IF PEOPLE ARE LIVING NEAR
FREEWAYS AND- YOU KNOW
EXPECTING MOTHERS ARE HURTING
AND- EVEN YOUR NEED TO. GO
THROUGH WE DON'T NEED TO GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE LIST BUT- WE
HAVE TO BE BOLD- MY MAIN
QUESTION FOR YOU IS JUST- ARE
WE BOTH ENOUGH- THE GOVERNOR
SENT A LETTER TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD I BELIEVE ON
FRIDAY- ASKING FOR THEM TO
STUDY- THE FEASIBILITY OF A-
NEAR TERM. APPROACH TO
NEUTRALITY ORDERED TEN AT ZERO-
I THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY GO
FURTHER THAN THAT ZERO I THINK
WE CAN GO TO NET NEGATIVE BY
THIRTY FIVE BASED ON THE MODELS
WE'VE SEEN. IT HOW DO YOU HOW
DO YOU WRESTLE WITH THAT WITH
THIS LEGISLATION ARE YOU
PRECLUDING US FROM THINKING
BIGGER IF TECHNOLOGY DOES
ENABLE LITERACY OR BOARD SAYS
WE HAVE TO WORK- TO MEET OUR
GOALS I MEAN. HOW DO YOU HOW DO
YOU WRESTLE WITH THAT SORT OF.
NOT THE FORTY FIVE VISION BUT
THAT THIRTY FIVE VISION.
ABSOLUTELY NOT CENTER AND IN
FACT I WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR BILL LEADERSHIP AND I KNOW
THAT YOU HAD. YOUR BILL THAT-
IT LOOKS LIKE THE GOVERNOR IS
FOLLOWING YOUR LEAD IN TERMS OF
CALLING. FOR EXPLORING AVENUES
TO THE POSSIBILITY OF ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY. BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE NOT NINE WAITING
UNTIL MID CENTURY LIKE. LIKE
THE REST OF THE WORLD I LIKE
ART LIKE AREN'T NOT A NATION
LIKE PRESIDENT BIDEN CALLED
FOR- BUT- FOR CALIFORNIA TO
REASSERT. ITS LEADERSHIP BY YOU
KNOW EXPLORING WAYS TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY BY NET
ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND SO
WE CERTAINLY WELCOME YOU KNOW
YOUR LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP- YOU KNOW
IN CALLING FOR THE A RP TO
EXPLORE THIS. THIS BILL- IS THE
BACKSTOP IT'S- EIGHT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PURSUING.
NET ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AS AGGRESSIVELY AND
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE TO
SAVE OUR PLANET FROM THE
EXTREME HEAT FROM THE DROUGHTS
FROM THE WILD FIRES. WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S WORKABLE THAT THAT THEY'VE
WORKABLE AND VERIFIABLE AND SO-
YOU KNOW. WAIT TO ALL THOSE WHO
SAY THAT THEY THEY CAN ENTER
VAPED ARE ARE YOU KNOW OUR WAY
OUT OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS MORE
POWER TO THEM YOU KNOW WE WANT
MORE CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
WE WANT MORE CARBON DIOXIDE
REMOVAL. BUT YOU KNOW LET'S
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT THAT TO
THAT THAT WE CAN DO IT IN A WAY
THAT THAT IS THAT IS ACHIEVABLE
AND THAT IS VERIFIABLE THE THAT
THE CRITERIA PORTIONS. AS IT
RELATES TO THE CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE IN THE CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL IT IT IT
DOESN'T LIMON THE TECHNOLOGY
THE INVESTMENTS IN IN ANY WAY
ALL IT DOES IS SAYING THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
NO GREENWASHING HAPPENING HERE.
THAT IS NOT BEING USED AS AN
EXCUSE TO CONTINUE TO IN THAT
MORE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
TO CONTINUE TO POLLUTE YOU KNOW
OUR OUR AIR AND SO YOU KNOW IT
THAT WE'RE WE'RE WORKING HAND
IN HAND. WITH THE BOLD CALLS
LIKE YOURS TO YOU KNOW A CHEAP
CAR NINE ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS EVEN EARLIER WELL
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN DO IT
IN A WAY THAT IS ACTUALLY T.
MOBILE AND VERIFIABLE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND WHAT I'M
HEARING YOU SAY ALSO AND I
THINK IT'S EXPLICIT IN THE
LANGUAGES THAT. IT'S A
BACKSTOPS BUT THERE'S NOTHING
THAT IT'S- IT IS SOON AS IT IS
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE RIGHT I
THINK THERE'S LANGUAGE IN HERE
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY SO NOTES
THE NOTES PROVISION BECAUSE
THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE THE
CONCERN IS IF WE SEE THE
SCOPING PLAN COME OUT FOR THIS
NEXT ROUND. AND CONTINUES TO
SORT OF LAG OR BE ON AMBITIOUS
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A NO
OVERHANG OF OVERSUPPLY SAY ANY
ALLOWANCE MARKET AND LETTING
MORE PEOPLE POLLUTE- AND THAT
SORT OF TWENTY THIRTY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE TRAJECTORY TO ME
FEELS LIKE THE INSURANCE POLICY
ESPECIALLY FOR THE FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES TO KNOW THAT THAT'S
GOING TO GET DONE. I THINK
YOU'VE GOT NOT JUST THE FORTY
FIVE LIMIT BUT I THINK BUT I
THINK SOME OF THE DIRECT
REDUCTION REQUIREMENTS WILL
ALSO PROVIDE SOME OF THAT
CERTAINTY- AND I REALLY HOPE
THAT THE AIRBOARD- HEEDS OUR
CALL HERE AND CONTINUES TO SORT
OF THINK BG TO PULL UP SHORT-
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AND I THINK
FOR BOTH OUR FRIENDS IN
INDUSTRY AND PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
INNOVATE AND CREATE JOBS WE GOT
TO THINK BIG BECAUSE- WE'RE
GOING TO LAG BEHIND IF WE KEEP
DOING IT THE OLD WAY AND SAME
WITH. OUR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES- SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE AND
APPLAUD YOU FOR IT I HOPE THAT
THE OPPONENTS ALSO STUDY SOME
OF THE PROVISIONS I KNOW
THEY'VE YET TO COME IN TO PRINT
SO HOPEFULLY BEFORE THE FLOOR
THERE THERE'S THAT SORT OF
DEPTH OF ENGAGEMENT BECAUSE THE
WAY I READ WHAT CAME FROM THAT
COMMITTEE. WAS A MUCH MORE-
SORT OF- A LESS PRESCRIPTIVE
APPROACH AS YOU SAID- ONE THAT
GIVES A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY TO
THAT KIND OF EXPERIMENTATION I
LOVE THE EMPHASIS ON PERMANENCE
I THINK THAT THAT CERTAINTY- IS
GOING TO BE CRITICAL AND IT
WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO BE
FOLLOW UP LEGISLATION IN SOME
WAY TO PROVIDE ENOUGH LEGAL
CERTAINTY AROUND THIS FRAMEWORK
WHEN YOU SAY YOU'RE COMMITTED
TO STORING THE CARBON FOREVER-
WHAT IS HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY
GUARANTEE FOREVER. AND WHAT
KIND OF INSTRUMENTS DO WE NEED
A LAW OR IN REGULATION- WHETHER
IT'S YOU KNOW AN INSURANCE POOL
FOR WAYS. TO SORT OF BUILD
TRUSTS OR OTHER GUARANTEE TEE'S
THERE'S A NUMBER OF MODELS
AROUND THE- THAT. AND IF UK'S.
AT A MODEL IN THE U. N. HAS A
PROPOSAL AND- BUT A LOT OF IT
HAS TO DO WITH. LAND RIGHTS AND
ESTABLISHING CERTAINTY AROUND-
THINGS LIKE. POOR RIGHTS EVEN
THE FEROCITY OF SOME OF THESE
FORMATIONS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE WERE GONNA INVEST
HOPEFULLY BILLIONS IN THE
CALIFORNIA TO DO THIS WORK.
KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW. THERE'S
GOING TO BE VERY HIGH STANDARD
ON THIS WORK BUT ALSO THAT. WE
LIKE YOU SAID. WE REALLY ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKE IT HAPPEN SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR BRAVE
THAT. PRONOUNCEMENT IN THAT
REGARD AND- YEAH MOVES ABILITY
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
OKAY SENT OUT. THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS NOT
REALLY SO MUCH ON THE BILL
PARTLY JUST SOME OBSERVATIONS
OF SOMEBODY WHOSE DISTRICT IS
BURNING UP RIGHT NOW THIS BILL
ISN'T GONNA CHANGE FORCE FIRED
ALL- IT MAY MAY REDUCE CARBON.
IT GOALS. BUT WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE. A 98%
REDUCTION IN CARBON BUT THEY
1100% IN THOSE IN THOSE
PROJECTS DON'T GET FUNDED. SO
AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE TOO
THAT THE A. R. B. WE JUST
APPOINTED A NEW OARD OF THE R.
B. BECAUSE THE LAST BOARD-
AUDIT CAME OUT WASN'T THAT WELL
AND SO GIVING THE POWER TO THE
A. R. B. I THINK IS- WITHOUT
SOME REALLY CLEAR DIRECTION ON
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT IT IS- AREA. RISKY
AND I KNOW THAT WE WILL BE HERE
I THINK WE CAME IN TOGETHER IN
THE SAME CLASS MAYBE MIGHT BE A
COUPLE YEARS LONGER THAN I AM
BUT I DID YOU KNOW THAT THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS ON HOW.
THESE REGULATORS BECAUSE WE'RE
GIVING THEM THE POWER YOU KNOW
GET IT DONE AND MY CONFIDENCE
IN THEM IS. NOT VERY HIGH AT
THIS POINT WE'VE SEEN THE
AUDITS COME BACK WERE. THE
MONEY THAT WE SPENT THROUGH THE
A. R. B. HASN'T REALLY ACHIEVED
MUCH WHEN IT COMES TO CARBON
REDUCTION AND I JUST WANNA
SHARE ONE LAST THING IS.
SOMEBODY WHO IS IN BUSINESS AND
TRYING TO SURVIVE IN CALIFORNIA
HAS THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS
CONTINUES TO. EXPLODE WE ARE
LEADING THE WORLD SUPPOSEDLY
IN. TECHNOLOGY AND CARBON
SEQUESTRATION AND TRYING TO
TRYING TO SHOW THE WORLD BUT
THE WORLD IS NOT. CATCHING UP
WITH US AND SO. ALL THE GAINS
WE MAKE HERE IF WE DON'T SECURE
THOSE JOBS. AND THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
MAKE THEM COMPETITIVE. QUITE
FRANKLY THE PRODUCTS THAT WE
NEED TO LIVE IN USE WILL JUST
BE DEVELOP SOMEWHERE ELSE. AND
THE AMOUNT OF CARBON THAT WILL
BE LATE RELEASED IN THOSE PROP
IN THE IN THOSE TO THE- AREAS
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
LAWS WE HAVE. DOES DOES NOTHING
FOR. THE CARBON OF THE WORLD
WE'REALL BREATHING THE SAME
CAR IN THE WORLD SO. THAT'S THE
FRUSTRATION FOR ME AS A
CALIFORNIAN WHO IS IN BUSINESS
HERE TRYING TO. STAY AFLOAT AND
IN ORDER TO KEEP MY BUSINESS
RUNNING AND PROVIDE THE THINGS
THAT PEOPLE NEED WHICH AS YOU
KNOW I'M A FARMER PEOPLE HAVE
TO EAT EVERY DAY. BUT IF I
CAN'T BE COMPETITIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. THOSE JOBS ARE
GOING TO GO SOME IS GOING TO
PROVIDE THE FOOD FOR SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND THEY'RE GONNA BE.
EMITTING CARBON IS TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGIES WE
HAVE AVAILABLE TODAY WE HAVE TO
USE THERE ISN'T. A SILVER
BULLET IN THE TECHNOLOGY TO.
MAKE MY HARVESTER BE ALL
ELECTRIC OR- WELL THIS ISN'T
AVAILABLE AND SO WE'RE
COMPETING WITH US I JUST WANT
TO SHARE SOME THOUGHTS WE HAVE
A LOT OF BILLS COME THROUGH
TODAY THAT I'M GOING TO BE
SAYING THE SAME THING ON IT'S
LIKE. YEAH WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO GET THERE BUT- I THINK THAT.
WE NEED TO. HAVE A MORE CLEAR
PLAN WITH THE AIR BOARD THAT IS
GOING TO BE RESPONSIVE TO. THE
NEEDS OF BEING COMPETITIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. MR CHERRY IF I MAKE
A THROUGH THE CHAIR- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR DOLLY I YOU
KNOW I. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
QUESTION OF JOBS I MEAN. YOU
KNOW THE REASON WHY I HAVE A
LOT MORE GRAY HAIR. NOW THAN
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED IN TWENTY
TWELVE IS- IS BECAUSE OF. YOU
KNOW THE CONSTANT- MY CONSTANT
CONCERN ARE COUNT CONSTANT
CONCERN ABOUT WHETHER WERE
DRIVING JOBS OUT OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- AND ESPECIALLY
YOU KNOW WHERE WHERE DEALS WITH
THIS. THIS CHALLENGE OF YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE- STOP THE
BUSINESS AS USUAL WHEN WE ARE
SEEING THESE. DISTURBING AND
ALARMING YOU KNOW DEVELOPMENTS
IN LA AND YOUR DISTRICT WITH
THE WILD FIRES IN THE DROUGHT I
MEAN I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THIS. IN OF ITSELF
CERTAINLY IS NOT GOING TO.
DIRECTLY YOU KNOW IT IMPACT THE
WILD FIRES AND YET. YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE TO
YOU KNOW LOOK NOT ONLY AT WHAT
THE SCIENTISTSARE SAYING BUT
WHAT WHAT THE REST OF THE WORLD
IS TRYING TO DO. AND I THINK
THERE IS THE GROWING CONSENSUS
THAT WE CANNOT APPROACH- OUR
OUR FIGHT AGAINST THE CLIMATE
CRISIS IN. BUSINESS AS USUAL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I MEAN I.
AGAIN I WANT TO- YOU KNOW.
EMPHASIZE THAT THAT WE WANT TO
SUPPORT AND INCENTIVIZE IS MUCH
OF THE INNOVATION AND THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD ALLOW.
BUSINESSES TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA- ECONOMICALLY- AS
WELL AS IN A WAY THAT'S NOT
CONTRIBUTING TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS THE LAST POINT I WANTED
TO ADDRESS IS THAT. YOU KNOW
EVER SINCE- YOU AND I ARRIVED
IN THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
TWELVE. WE HAVE CONSTANTLY
HEARD THAT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD IS HAS NO OVERSIGHT FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND SO THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK THE LEGISLATURE'S
FRAMEWORK ON THE A. R. B. TO
GUIDE. THE A. R. B. ON HOW TO
ACHIEVE THE NET ZERO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AS WELL AS TO
PROVIDE THE BASIC CRITERIA THE
BASIC FRAMEWORK YOU KNOW ON ON
HOW TO REGULATE THE CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE OF CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL TECHNOLOGIES
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE NEED
WE JUST TAKE THE WHOLE PLAN AND
DESPERATELY NEEDS TO FIGHT THIS
CLIMATE CRISIS. AND SO THIS I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS IS THE LEGISLATURE'S
ATTEMPT TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW THE
OVERSIGHT THE GUIDANCE IN THE
FRAMEWORK- AND- TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. AN INMATE
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER FUJI
AND CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YEAR PASSION ABOUT THE
FIRE- THAT WE ALL SHARE I THINK
WE'LL PROBABLY LOOK AT IT A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY AND HOPE
THEY'RE BETTER PATHWAYS SIDE TO
GETTING THERE YOU SAID WE- WANT
THESE THINGS TO HAPPEN AND I'M
ALWAYS KIND OF A DISBELIEVE- AT
THAT SHOP WE GET INVOLVED WITH
CARBS HOW WE SEND THEM THESE.
TOOLS WHICH SOMETIMES ARE VERY
ELUSIVE AND EXPECT IT JUST TO
HAPPEN AND NEVER COMES BACK
HERE RIGHT NOW I THINK WE HAVE
THE AN AUDIT THAT SAYS THEY
AREN'T EVEN CERTAIN ABOUT
MEETING THE GOALS AND TWENTY
THIRTY HARM BASED ON A SCOPING
PLAN THAT STILL IS THE ALL
INCLUSIVE IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE
THE PATHWAYS AND I GUESS ONE OF
MY QUESTIONS IS GOING TO BE ON.
WHY IT WHY IS THERE AN URGENCY
TO MOVE THIS BILL BEFORE THAT
PROCESS FOR SB THIRTY TWO IS
COMPLETED LET ME THROW ANOTHER
ONE BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM. OUR
THE MULTITUDE OF OPPOSITION
THAT YOU HEARD THERE THERE IS
FEAR OBVIOUSLY COMING OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC COMING OUT OF. A
RECESSION THAT'S NOT THAT MANY
YEARS AGO OUR ECONOMY IS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED-
CERTAINLY MOVING TO GREEN JOBS
HASN'T BEEN AS- FAVORITE. AS
WAS ASSUME SO. I'LL HAVE THE
MANY ANALYSIS ALONG THE WAY OF
WHAT THESE ARE TARGETS MEAN FOR
THE ECONOMY. ARE IS THERE ANY
CONSIDERATION FOR THE COST
EFFECTIVE ENOUGH THAT THAT
SHOULD BE ANALYZE AND- INFER
FINALLY ARM I DON'T THINK
THERE'D BE THE IF- HUGE.
OPPOSITION IF THERE HAD BEEN
MORE OUR DISCUSSION NOW WITH
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHICH I BELIEVE.
OCCURRED AT IN THE PREVIOUS-
TARGETS THAT WERE SET. WHAT ANY
OF THAT. IF ON YOU STILL HAVE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF OPPOSITION SO
MAYBE YOU CAN TAKE THEM ALL
TOGETHER TALK TO US ABOUT. HOW
WE'RE GONNA GET THERE WHEN THE
SCOPING PLAN RIGHT NOW STILL
ELUSIVE- IS THERE GOING TO BE
COST EFFECTIVENESS THAT'S
REQUIRED F CARD TO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHEN THEY START DOWN THAT
PATH AND FRANKLY WOULDN'T
WONDERFUL PATHWAY. WHAT ARE THE
PATHWAYS WE HAVEN'T EVEN HAD A
REAL IN DEPTH DISCUSSION OF
THAT. ARE HOW WE GET AND WHAT
TECHNOLOGIES ARE OUT THERE IT'S
VERY INTERESTING WHEN YOU SPENT
A WEEKEND WATCHING AN
INDIVIDUAL GET US TO THE EDGE
OF SPACE BECAUSE HE DECIDED WE
NEEDED TO DO THAT. AND I DIDN'T
GET HUNG UP IN THE BUREAUCRACY
AND WHEN WE HAVE THOSE
INNOVATORS OUT THERE AND WE-
RESTRAIN THEM WITH THE
BUREAUCRACY THAT THIS KIND OF
STUFF- UP- HOW ARE WE GOING TO
GET THOSE TECHNOLOGIES IT FOR
NOT LETTING. EVERYBODY HAVE A
HAVE A FAIR SHOT AT IT AND NOT
GOING TO CARVE ON ALL OF THIS
SO. THAT'S KIND OF MY- PROBLEM.
WITH WHAT THIS PRESENTS OF THE
SOLUTION- I THINK IT'S VERY
RESTRAINING FRANKLY BUT HAVE AT
IT. TALK TO US ABOUT TARA HOW
WE'RE GOING TO YOU KNOW HAVE
SOMETHING THAT REALLY IS GOING
TO WORK IN THE SHORTER TERM IN
THE SHORTER TERM FRANKLY IS
TWENTY THIRTY. AND WHAT ARE WE
WERE JUST NINE YEARS ON THAT
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU SENATOR SO
YOU RISE SEVERAL POINTS AND- I
WANT TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
ADDRESS ALL OF THEM- GOING
GOING BY BACKWARDS- FEFE FROM
YOUR LAST POINT I MEAN I WAS
WATCHING THIS IS THE SAME- YOU
KNOW NEWS ABOUT- SIR BRANSON-
USING HIS- IS IT HAS AS WELL UP
TO OPEN UP- THAT THIS- THIS NEW
EXCITING FRONTIER- THE DOES
DOES THE PROSPECT OF COMMERCIAL
SPACE TOURISM. AND YOU KNOW-
YOU GUYS HAVE THE SAME I HAVE A
SIMILAR THOUGHT AS AS AS YOU
JUSTICE STATED THAT IDEA YOU
KNOW. I WISH THAT- SIR BRANSON
WOULD USE HIS- HIS WEALTH AND
HIS POWER TO. PURSUE WITHIN
THEIR THE BE- AN INVASION THAT
WE SO DESPERATELY NEED TO FIGHT
THIS CLIMATE CRISIS. I WOULD
TO. I ON ON YOUR POINT OF
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION OF A WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD TO OF MY
STAFF HAS BEEN SPENDING
COUNTLESS OUR HOURS MEETING
WITH DISCUSSING THIS BILL- AND
WE HAVE ALL ALONG BEEN
COMPLETE. YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
INVITING WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR
SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS ON ON HOW
TO MAKE THIS BILL WORKABLE FOR
EVERYONE FOR NOT ONLY TO
ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS BUT
FOR OUR BUSINESSES FOR JOBS I
MEAN YOU KNOW FOR ME THERE'S
NOTHING THAT GIVES ME MORE GRAY
HAIR THAN HAVING TO GO AGAINST
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND ALL OF
THEIR THEIR MEMBERSHIP YOU KNOW
WHO. YOU KNOW WHO I. YOU KNOW I
MEAN IN SO MANY WAYS OVER THE
YEARS THAT I'VE THAT I'VE TRIED
TO SUPPORT. AND YET YOU KNOW
WHEN IT COMES TO. WE WE'VE SEEN
THIS THIS THIS- THEME
CONSTANTLY PLAY OUT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN HOW DO WE ACHIEVE.
YOU KNOW OUR CLIMATE GOALS HOW
DO WE FIGHT THE CLIMATE CRISIS
WELL AT THE SAME TIME. YOU KNOW
SUPPORT THESE THESE GOOD UNION
JOBS THESE THESE THESE THESE
BUSINESSES AND OUR STATE. AND
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S A- IT AGAIN
IT'S WHAT GIVES ME ALL THIS
GRAY HAIR I MEAN IT'S A- SO I
WOULD ASK YOU YOU KNOW IF THERE
IS. I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANYTHING IN THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL THAT
WOULD CONSTRAIN. YOU KNOW THE
INNOVATION THE INVESTMENTS IN
THE INNOVATIONS IF YOU HAVE IN
A SPECIFIC UGH- PROPOSAL
SPECIFIC PASSAGES THAT YOU HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT I YOU KNOW I
THINK I CAN ADDRESS THEM- BUT-
YOU KNOW I'D I WOULD DIG. IT
CONTINUE TO INVITE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM- ANYONE THAT CALLED
AND- ANYONE THAT'S IN
OPPOSITION OR HAS CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL YOU KNOW I WILL
PERSONALLY WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THEM. TO TO ADD TO IT TOO DOES
IT TO SEE IF WE CAN COME UP
WITH- WITH LANGUAGE TO MAKE
THIS BILL WORK FOR ALL OF US
BUT THE I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THIS THE END OF THAT. THAT
THE WE CAN'T CONTINUE WITH
BUSINESS AS USUAL I MEAN WE ARE
WE ARE ON THE FRONT LINES WE
ARE THE BOILING FROGS. YOU KNOW
AND WE AND WE ARE LITERALLY
SEEING AT THIS PAST WEEKEND THE
EXTREME HEAT THE WILD FIRES THE
DROUGHT SO MEAN I. SOUND LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD BUT- YOU KNOW. WE
CAN'T CONTINUE WITH BUSINESS AS
USUAL AND THAT THAT IS WHAT I'M
PROPOSING HERE. WELL I THINK
YOU AYE I GAVE YOU KIND OF A
WHOLE PANOPLY OF. ISSUES THAT
CERTAINLY TROUBLED ME I'M JUST
WONDERING WHY WE'RE NOT USING
ALL THE SOME OF THE TOOLS THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TO GET THEIR
LIKE EXTENSION OF CAP AND
TRADE. AND LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD WHAT DO YOU ENVISION
AS BEING THE TOOLS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO USE GOING FORWARD THE
USER RIGHT HERE RIGHT NOW. AND
I GUESS LET ME. EMPHASIZE
THERE'S NO URGENCY IF. AND YOU
HAVE URGENCY IN THIS BILL. WHAT
IS THE URGENCY IF WE DO NOT YET
MEET WHAT WE PREDICTED IN OUR
WHAT WE ASK FOR AN SB THIRTY
TWO. BY TWENTY THIRTY. WE'RE
NOT THERE AND WE JUST HAD AN
AUDIT THAT SAID IT'S STILL VERY
LOOSELY. THEN I THINK THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT ARE TROUBLING
FOR US WHO BELIEVE. AND SEE IT
HAPPENING I LIVE ON THE COAST
ICC RISE I SEE PEOPLE HAVING TO
PUT ANOTHER WALL. ANOTHER I
THINK OF AN INCH AND A HALF
EIGHTEEN INCHES ON THE FRONT OF
THEIR- THEIR BOAT AREAS IN
NEWPORT BEACH BECAUSE THEY'RE
BEING SWAMPED ARE WHEN WE GET
THE KING TIDES IT'S HAPPENING.
BUT WHEN WE COME UP WITH THINGS
THAT. YOU KNOW LARGEST THEY'RE
THEY'RE GREAT SOUNDING THEIR
GREAT WORDS BUT WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE LIVING OUT LIKE MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FRIEND BIEBER HERE.
AND HE'S SAYING THAT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
THERE. ARE ARE NOT APPROVED OF
THE WAY TO SEQUESTER CARBON. SO
WE CAN'T JUST KEEP TALKING
ABOUT IT AND ALEC NOREEN I
DON'T THINK THE THINGS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY THERE. THEY SHOULD
GET SOME SORT OF STANDARD. ON
THE ON THE CONTINUUM OF HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE WE
DON'T HAVE A CONTINUUM WE'RE
JUST SAYING DO IT. IN THAT GET
PUT IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE THAT
CAN BE EXTREMELY EXTREMELY. ARE
RESTRAINING ON IDEAS AND
IMMEDIATELY HURT. OUR BUSINESS
AND JOB CREATION. IN THAT HAVE
TO BE AN EQUATION WHERE THERE'S
BALANCE ON BOTH SIDES OR WILL
SAVE A PLANET- FOR SOMEONE BUT
THE PEOPLE. WHO REALLY NEED TO
LIVE HERE THE ANIMALS ON THE-
FLOOR AND THE FUN AND THE
PEOPLE THERE WON'T BE ANYTHING
FOR THEM BECAUSE REMEMBER. YOU
CAN'T SUPPORT ALL OF THESE
THINGS UNLESS YOU'VE GOT A
REVENUE STREAM AND WE ARE
KILLING THE REVENUE STREAM AS
WE GO ALONG AND THAT TROUBLES
ME I'VE SEEN IT AND I
COMMUNITIES. AND I LIVE IN
ENOUGH AFFLUENT COMMUNITY. SO
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS
OBVIOUSLY ACCOUNT SUPPORT IT
TODAY BUT- I DO- YOU KNOW
CHALLENGE YOU. I PLEDGE YOU AND
CHALLENGE YOU IF YOU WANT TO BE
THE LEAD ON THIS. COME UP WITH.
SOME THINGS THAT ARE MORE
TANGIBLE. REASONABLE AND YOU
KNOW REAL TIME. BECAUSE THE DO
NOT. SEEM TO BE IN THE IN THE
CONFIDANT MOVING THE TARGET
FORWARD. PUTTING HUGE GOALS ON
THERE BUT SAY DO IT AND HOLD
OVER ON THIS SIDE OF THE
EQUATION THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
ARE GOING TO SAVE US. THE
VIOLENCE SEEN IT YET. WHAT WHEN
WE GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THOSE. ISSUES IN YOUR
CLOTHES- YEAH THAT'S FINE. YEAH
THE TOP. GO FOR IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU TO EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU FOR YOUR YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS YOUR CONCERNS- GOING
GO BACK TO CENTER BATES IS-
CONCERNS AYE AYE I WANNA MAKE
IT ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT THAT
THIS BILL IS NOT TO REPLACE ANY
OF THE- GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS AND SB THIRTY
TWO THAT- THAT LAYS OUT THE
THAT THE TWENTY THIRTY TARGETS
AND EFFECTIVE THAT IS ONE OF
THE- THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
TO CLARIFY THAT THE NEW TWENTY
FORTY FIVE CLIMB MICHAEL SHALL
NOT TAKE PRECEDENT OR SUPERSEDE
MUSIC THE EXISTING TWENTY
THIRTY GHG REDUCTION TARGETS
THIS IS THIS THIS IS THE NEXT
STEP IS THAT WE STARTED WITH
WITH THE AB THIRTY TWO- WE
REACH THOSE GOALS- IN AN
ADVANCE OF THE SCHEDULE- THERE
WE THEN- A PAST SEVEN. SB
THIRTY TWO. THE FIRST IS AB
THIRTY TWO THE SECOND WAS SB
THIRTY TWO WHICH WHICH SET THE
NEW GOALS FOR TWENTY THIRTY YOU
KNOW THE AUDIT IT DID SHOW THAT
TO. THAT THE IT IS YOU KNOW WE
DO WE DO HAVE OUR CHALLENGES
AND THAT WE DO NEED TO.
EXERCISE MORE OVERSIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD IS DOING WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE AT HAD MANDATE IT
TO DO- UNDER SB THIRTY TWO. BUT
THIS IS THE NEXT STEP THIS IS
LOOKING BEYOND LIKE THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY LIKE PRESIDENT
BIDEN LIKE THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS DOING IS WHAT ARE WE
DOING IF WE DON'T GET TO.
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY MID
CENTURY WE- YOU KNOW. WE HAVE
NO FUTURE FOR OUR CHILDREN OUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND THEREAFTER-
AS AS AS AS WE KNOW IT WE YOU
KNOW WE WILL IRREVERSIBLY
CHANGE- OUR PLANET AND OUR
CLIMATE- I AT THAT POINT AND SO.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
IN NO WAY- YOU KNOW SEEKS TO
UNDERMINE OR SUPERSEDE OR
REPLACE- YOU'D BE SB THIRTY TO
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO HOLD THEIR PEACE
FEET TO HIS. TO THE FIRE TO-
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE BUT THIS
IS BEYOND THAT- AND- THE
BLASTED IT YOU KNOW AGE
ADJUSTED CLOSE I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH ALL ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION- ESPECIALLY ON THE
JOBS QUESTION I MEAN THAT- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT THAT IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT IT
THAT- THIS ENTIRE LEGISLATURES
FACING IN TERMS OF. ITS OF.
PURSUING IT SAID AS ITS CLIMATE
GOALS- BUT LET ME JUST WRAP UP
BY SAYING THAT- THAT- WE ARE
CERTAINLY NOT ALONE IN THIS
EFFORT I MEAN- OTHER STATES THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON. JUST
PASSED A LAW THAT CALLS FOR A
95% DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTION
BY TWENTY FIVE OF FIFTY AND SO.
IT YOU KNOW THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON PASSED THE LAW IN
THE STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS LAST
YEAR- A PASS A LAW TO ACHIEVE
CARBON- TWO EIGHT NINE ZERO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS-
EMISSIONS- BY TWENTY FIFTY. SO
I MEAN. WE ARE JUST TRYING TO
CATCH UP WITH THE REST OF THE
WORLD IN RECOGNIZING AND
LISTENING TO THE SCIENTISTS
THAT IF WE DON'T ACHIEVE NET
ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BY MID CENTURY. WE ARE NOT
DOING A SERVICE FOR ITS
CHILDREN GRANTS AND
GRANDCHILDREN SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU I MEAN IT THE
CHALLENGE IS IT'S- REALLY FOR.
OUR GRANDCHILDREN ARE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN I MEAN IT IS ONE
OF THE GREAT ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE HERE THAT IT'S ALL ABOUT
WHAT PEOPLE CAN SEE. AND YET-
YOU KNOW. YOUR THROUGH THE
SCIENTIFIC ANALYSES THE REAL
IMPACTS THE DESERVED. REAL LIFE
CHANGING IMPACTS AND OUR LIVES
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO CHANGE
AS YOU SAY THAT THE BOILING
WATER- THE FROG ANALOGY BUT-
THE- BUT- IT'S NOT A PLEASANT
TOPIC BUT IT WHEN YOU REALLY
START TO GO THROUGH SOME OF THE
FORECASTS IT'S VERY UNPLEASANT-
BUT BUT- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT- MOST OF US ARE
NOT GOING TO BE AROUND- AND
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY THIS SUCH
A DIFFICULT ISSUE TO TAKE
COLLECTIVE ACTION ON AND- AND-
AND THE COLLECTIVE ACTION ISSUE
ISRAEL I WAS HAVING A LITTLE
SIDE BAR WITH. OUR COLLEAGUE ON
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT GOOD IS
ALL THIS IS CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
ONE DOING THIS KIND OF WORK.
COURSE ARE A LOT OF OTHER FOLKS
DOING WORK IN THE SPACE- BUT
IT'S JUST SUCH AN A SUCH AN
EXTENSION CRISIS. AND. SO I'M
I'M REALLY SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY I ACTUALLY HOPE THAT AS
WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WE
FIND WAYS TO ADDRESS ALL OF THE
MANY ISSUES WE CERTAINLY
ADDRESSED THIS NUMBER OF
INDUSTRY ISSUES IN THE
AMENDMENTS- IN A WAY THAT I
THINK STILL KEEP YOUR BILL
STRONG- BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT I
THINK OF AN EXPRESSED TODAY BY
OPPOSITION I CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE YOU AND HOPE THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS FROM. LABOR
AND INDUSTRY AND OTHERS- TO SEE
SEE WHAT WE CAN. HOW MUCH
PROGRESS WE CAN MAKE ON THIS
BILL- IF THE BILL CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD- BUT I DO APPLAUD
YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS-
TRULY EXISTENTIAL ISSUE FOR
OUR- OUR- OUR SPECIES ARE
PLANET. AND THE BILL'S AND
MOVED BY SENATOR CASKEY AT.
CONCERT WITH CHOLERA. I AM
NUMBER ONE AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERIT CG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN HI ALAN I
BATES. DALLY. YES SKINNER STERN
Y. CASKEY HI ASKI I'D. OKAY
WELL THAT OPEN FOR THE FOLKS
THAT ON AND- LOOK FOR TO THAT
NEGOTIATION DISCUSSION
CONTINUING- WITH. ONE TO TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH BILL THIS IS
SEN. AB. ONE SEVENTEEN. WE NEED
YOU CAN PRESENTED AFTER TEN SO
WE MADE SURE THAT THIS IS A
LONG MEDIA BILL. BEFORE YOU- SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR-
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL ON
ELECTRIC BICYCLES. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FLEXIBILITY ALSO
WITH THE SCHEDULING TODAY TODAY
I AM PRESENTING AB ONE
SEVENTEEN A BILL TO ALLOW T. BY
CONSENT IS TO BE ONE OF THE
PRIORITIES ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING
UNDER THE AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM. BY
INCREASING E. BIKE ADOPTION WE
ARE ABLE TO REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED A RECENT STUDY
OF NORTH AMERICAN E. BIKE OR
SHOWS THAT NEARLY HALF OR 46%
OF E. BIKE COMMUTE TRIPS
REPLACED AUTOMOBILE COMMUTERS
AND I CAN ATTEST THAT A
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE. THIS WEEKEND
WE TOOK ALMOST ALL OF OUR TRIPS
AROUND TOWN ON OUR E. BIKES AND
NOT OUR CARS TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS WE
MUST WORK TO REDUCE THESE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
REPLACE THEM WITH CLEANER
ALTERNATIVES HE BY COULD OPTION
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THE LAST YEAR BUT COSTS
REMAIN A FACTOR AND
AVAILABILITY FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS. AS I NOTED IN
PRIOR COMMITTEES- I AM WORKING
ON AMENDMENTS THAT WILL ENSURE
THE PROGRAM PRIORITIZES LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS INCLUDING
THOSE AT INCLUDING THE USE OF A
SALARY CAP SO THESE INCENTIVES
GET TO THOSE WHO ACTUALLY NEED
THE HELP. THEY MEMBERS WOULD
ALSO STRUCTURE THIS AS A
VOUCHER PROGRAM FOR ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE PRE APPROVED
FOR INCENTIVES AND WALK INTO A
PARTICIPATING RETAILER TO
PURCHASE AN EVIL BIKE USING THE
VOUCHER. FINALLY OUR POINT PLAN
AMENDMENTS WILL HELP ENSURE
INCENTIVES CAN BE USED FOR A
VARIETY OF QUALITY E. BIKE
MODELS THAT A SMALL PORTION OF
THE FUNDING ALLOCATED TO THIS
PROGRAM WILL GO TO E. BIKE
EDUCATION I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IF YOU'RE A LOT OF E.
BIKES IN TOWN WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO SEND YOU BACK EDUCATION
WITH THEM. SAFETY PROGRAMS AND
PROGRAM PROMOTION ENSURE
APPROPRIATE REGULATIONS TO
PREVENT. FRAUD AND ABUSE OF THE
PROGRAM. CENTERS AB ONE SEVENTY
MAKE A- MORE. FOR CAL. ALONG
MORE PEOPLE TO ADOPT THIS
CLEANER HOW. FORM TRANSPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ARE WITNESSES COULDN'T
MAKE IT THIS MORNING SO. WE GO
STRAIGHT. THE OF PART OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT- PUTS MODERATOR
OKAY WE HAVE WE HAVE SOMEONE
HERE PERCENT. WARNING MEMBERS
DON'T GET ALONG WITH COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE SEVENTEEN I'M A REGULAR T.
BIKE USER BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL MAKE THESE EXCELLENT
VEHICLES AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE
WHO WOULD NOT OTHERWISE HAVE
ACCESS TO THEM AND THEY DO
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND REDUCE THE EMISSIONS THAT
ARE CAUSING BOTH AIR POLLUTION
AND CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK YOU.
LINES FOR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
AB ONE SEVENTEEN THE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK TO THE QUEUE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
REPLY NUMBER SEVENTY THREE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN TURN MEMBERS
MAKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS AS KIRK BLACKBURN
WITH THE SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS VANDAAG AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
NATALIE MACCABI HAVE A
CHARACTER ARC IN SUPPORT. BLIND
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS SAID DR JIM STEWART- GREAT
TO HAVE THIS EQUITY. THANKS TO
SUPPORT IT. MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS ARE GONNA
COME OUT TO ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND WORK THANK YOU. NUMBER MY
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BILL
MURPHY FOR ELDERS CLIMATE
ACTION IS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT. RIGHT
NUMBER ONE NUMBER ONE FORTY
SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE SENATE THE CAR
MAYBE A LINE THEN YOU LIE. ONE
FORTY SEVEN. BY ONE SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY GOOD MORNING IS
STEVE ALL COMING OUT THE
CALGARY BICYCLE COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATHY
GRIFFIN WITH THE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
ONE ONE SEVEN THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY WACO TO REPRESENTING UPPER
RECREATION USERS SUPPORT AB ONE
SEVENTEEN. AND AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE CAN QUEUE. OKAY I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION- WHICH REALLY DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES THAT HAVE
TESTED YOU KNOW TO COME FORWARD
IS THERE ANYONE WANTS OR
EXPRESS CONCERNS I DON'T SENIOR
PERSON. ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES HE WANTS TO EXPRESS ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL AB ONE
SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE SEVENTEEN. PLEASE
PRESS NE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
A LINE NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AB ONE
ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. AND AT THIS TIME
IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE TO
YOU OKAY ALL RIGHT WILL BRING
THE BILL BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
CENTER CASKEY. I HEARD YOU WHEN
YOU PRESENT A BILL THAT YOU'VE-
INDICATED THAT PEOPLE ARE GONNA
BY THE C. BIKES AND THEY'RE
GONNA GET OUT OF THEIR CARS AND
DRIVE AROUND TOWN AND YOU.
DRIVE AROUND TOWN AND I. APSLEY
GREETED THE VOUCHERS AND HAVING
THIS. AVAILABLE WITH THE EQUIP
WILL MAKE IT MORE AFFORDABLE
BUT- THE STAFF REPORT INDICATES
AT LEAST. IN EUROPE TO SIX X.
EXHAUSTIVE STUDIES THEY CAME UP
TO SAY REALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT YOU GET PEOPLE WHO ARE
REGULAR BICYCLE RIDERS. SWITCH
THE BIG MOVEMENT IS THE BICYCLE
RIDERS SWITCHING TO E. BIKES
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF PEOPLE
GETTING OUT OF THEIR CARS. AND-
DOING ANY PART I GUESS IS
THERE'S TWO STUDIES. I DIDN'T I
MISS WERE YOU. IT I GUESS THE
EVIDENCE THAT YOU HAD THAT THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THIS- WATERFALL OF PEOPLE MY
ANY BIKES WITH THIS LEGISLATION
SO FAR COULD SENATOR I THINK
THE IMPORTANT THING IS WHO CAN
AFFORD THEM AND I THINK IN
EUROPE AS SOMEBODY WHO LIVED IN
EUROPE FOR TWELVE YEARS AND
RODE MY BIKE EVERYWHERE BY
COMMUTED- MANY PLACES IN EUROPE
ARE VERY FLAT WHERE I LIVED- IT
WAS EASY TO RIDE MY BIKE. EVERY
DAY MANY PLACES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE NOT FLAT SO MY TOWN FOR
EXAMPLE IS A LOT OF BIG HILLS.
TO GO TO AND THAT WOULD BE
PROHIBITIVE FOR A LOT OF
RECREATIONAL USERS TO USE A
REGULAR BICYCLE. AND WHAT
YOU'LL SEE IS YOU'LL SEE
ADOPTION OF A WIDER RANGE. IN
CALIFORNIA OF THOSE WHO
ADOPTING EVEN MAKES- FIRST OF
ALL AND SECOND OF ALL- I THINK
WHEN WE LOOK AT GENERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN EUROPE VERSUS
A CALIFORNIA. FOR BIKES IT'S
QUITE DIFFERENT SO I'M NOT SURE
EUROPEAN STUDY COULD REALLY IS
REALLY ACCURATE FOR DESCRIBING
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE AS A CYCLIST. THEY
ARE EQUIVALENT ME AND I KNOW
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE MYSELF IF I
USED TO BUY COMMUTE. AND SO I
WHEN WE MOVED BACK HERE FROM
GERMANY I GOT A TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR HE JODY BIKE. AND THAT
REPLACE THE CAR WITH HIM BY A
SECOND CAR. AND I BY COMMUNITY
GO SEVEN MILES MEDICAL DOES
GIANT HELL. AND I WOULD NOT
HAVE DONE THAT HAD I NOT HAD AN
E. BIKE. NOW I CAN AFFORD IT SO
I'M NOT THE TARGET OF THIS BILL
THERE ARE MANY CALIFORNIANS
THOUGH WHO NEED THAT AND CENTER
VOUCHER. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO- ACTUALLY ADOPT IT AND AS I
SAID THIS WEEKEND WE WENT TO
THE BEACH ONCE AND WE DIDN'T
TAKE A CAR. WE WENT TO THE
STORE TO PICK UP MY MEN'S
BECAUSE WE WERE DOING MY
MANDATE- AND WE DON'T USE A
CAR. SO THE STUDY THAT WE'RE
CITING SHOWS 43% OF E. BIKE
OWNERS REPLACE CAR TRIPS WITH
BIKE TRIPS AND THAT'S THE TYPE
OF EMISSIONS REDUCTION. THAT WE
WANT TO SEE WITH THIS PROGRAM.
AND WE WANT TO SEE IT.
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
PRESSURE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. WELL I'M GOOD I'M
ALL MOVED A BILL I'M JUST
SAYING THAT YOU HAVE A STEADY
THERE'S OTHER TO OTHER STUDIES
THERE. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
INTO TOTAL INFORMATION AND I
THINK OF JIM BELL WE'RE SITTING
UP HERE. HE WOULD SAY THE
AMOUNT OF GREEN PAINT THAT'S
BEING SPENT BY CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO PUT BY CLINGS AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. FOR SB
ONE IS. FOR IS CHANGING THE
LAND. I MEAN YOU GO A LOT OF US.
RIGHT WHAT WE MAY NOT. ALL IN
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF BIKE LANES
ARE BEING PUT RIGHT NOW I THINK
THE LAST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
HAVE BEEN EXTRAORDINARY AT
LEAST IN THE BAY AREA WHERE
I'VE GONE RUNNING SO ALL USE
IT- EIGHT ATTENTION I HOPE
IT'S- WILDLY SUCCESSFUL BUT I'M
JUST SAYING THAT THE
INFORMATION THEY'RE SAYING IS.
IT IS SHOWING IS THAT YES FOR
THE WEEKEND WE MIGHT NOT DO IT
BUT FOR FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE HI I
AM I AM. I JUST BRING IT UP
BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ORDINARILY THEY'RE
ALREADY RIDING BIKES AND THEY
GO TO GO TO THE E. BIKE WHICH
IS THE BIG SHIFT WHICH- MIGHT
BE A GOOD THING YOU KNOW HE
LESS SWEATY WHEN YOU SHOP AT
WORK WELL AND I WAS THAT'S WHAT
IT DOES TO BE HONEST LIKE
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
YOU MIGHT WORKED. I WOULD
QUESTION THE USING STUDIES FROM
EUROPE THAT HAS A VERY
DIFFERENT LANDSCAPE HAS A
DIFFERENT TRANSIT LANDSCAPE
THEN WE HAVE MAYBE THE BAY AREA
APPROXIMATES IT MORE THAN THAT
IN MY AREA OF NORTH COUNTY SAN
DIEGO- ABOUT I HEAR IT I HEAR
YOUR POINT THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT IT. BUT I DO THINK THIS BILL
IS ABOUT MAKING IT A YOU KNOW
MAKING E. BIKES ACCESSIBLE AND
REPLACING CAR TRIPS AND I WOULD
SAY MOST OF EUROPE IS NOT
DEPENDENT ON A CAR IN THE SAME
WAY THAT WE IN CALIFORNIA ARE.
SO. REPLACING THOSE TRIPS I
THINK ARE REALLY IMPORTANT. YES
HI- ARGUMENTS FOR A BILL THAT I
TEST IS TAKING IF YOU'RE
GETTING. OFF OF A BICYCLE ON A
BIKE YOU'RE ACTUALLY IMPACTING
THE ENVIRONMENT MORE BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO CHARGE E. BIKE
SOMEWHERE. BUT WITH THAT BEING
SAID THE GOAL IS TO. ICE ICE I
SEE PEOPLE USING THIS FOR SHORT
RUNS AND NOT NOT USING AN
AUDIBLE BILL. IT'S EASIER TO
PARK EASIER TO GET WHERE YOU
WANT TO GO SO- AND I AND ALSO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNES WHERE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO. PURCHASE SEVERAL OF THE-
ELECTRIC CAR WOULD PREFERRED TO
GET. A BIKE THAT THEY CAN GET
AROUND ON WHICH IS GONNA BE
BETTER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND
BETTER FOR THE POCKETBOOK AT
THE SAME TIME WE CAN
INCENTIVIZE THAT SO. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU YEP. I STILL
LIKE THE OLD FASHIONED BY
EXPERT I AM- I RIDE VERY
FREQUENTLY BUT- HEY YOU KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE INTO THIS- I
THINK IT IS IT COULD BE A REAL
GAME CHANGER FOR COMMUTERS-
ESPECIALLY FOLKS WHO ARE. AND
GOING FURTHER AND I YOU KNOW OF
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTED THIS
IN TRANSPORTATION- I'M
CERTAINLY SUPPORTING IT HERE
AND I LIKE THE- INCENTIVE
SYSTEM ALSO EXCITED ABOUT SOME
OF THE- TRANSFORMATION THAT
CENTER CASKETS TALKING ABOUT
TERMS OF A BIKE LANES- MORE
MORE AROUND. HAS SO. LET'S GO
FORWARD WITH THIS- DO YOU WANT
ME TO CLOSE AYE I'VE YOU'VE
MOVED BILL YES OKAY RESULT
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ABOUT VOTE OKAY- HI AND- IT'S
ON CHOLERA. I NUMBER TWO. ONE
SEVENTEEN. FIVE FOUR EVA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOARD A BATH-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN HI ALLEN
AYE BATES. DALLI DALLY I
GONZALEZ. INNER STERN BY
CASKEY. HI MY CASKEY I'M- OKAY
THANK YOU. THIRTY TEST OKAY- I
AM SUPPOSED TO ANNOUNCE THE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION NUMBER ONE
MORE TIME AS WE WAIT FOR THE
GUYS TO BE CLEANED AND I AND I
GUESS I LOSE WILL BE PRESENTING
NEXT THIS IS EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE. FOLKS THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS 877-692-8953 THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN OH FIVE
SIX NINE OH NINE. THIS POST
ABOUT ONE FOR SUPPORT ZERO
PROPOSITION I KNOW THE PHONE
LINES OF AND A TOTAL MESS THIS
MORNING BECAUSE OF. THE
PREVIOUS BILL AT THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE- I'M GETTING
NOTHING BUT. UPSET FOLKS ABOUT
THE LOG JAM BUT THIS IS THE
CRAZY SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE SO
THERE WE ARE- PRISON NUMBER
ONCE AGAIN 877-692-8953 ACCESS
CODE SEVEN OH FIVE SIX NINE OH
NINE LET'S PROCEED WITH SOME
NUMBER RIVAS. WHO'S YOUR
PERCENT. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS. I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE. I
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS SUMMARIZED ON PAGE
TEN OF THE ANALYSIS. AND I WANT
TO THANK RILEY FOR HER WORK ON
THIS BILL. AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
COURT DATE STATE EFFORTS TO
HELP URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES COMBAT EXTREME
HEAT. BY CREATING THE EXTREME
HEAT AND COMMUNITY ROOM
RESILIENCE PROGRAM UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. THE PROGRAM
ESTABLISHES GUIDELINES FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS AND
HELPS LOCAL ENTITIES IMPLEMENT
MEASURES THAT REDUCE EXTREME
HATE. THE FIVE HOTTEST YEARS ON
RECORD AND IN ORDER OUR
201-620-2020 NINETEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THESE RECORD BREAKING HEAT
WAVES HAVE LED TO MORE POWER
OUTAGES COMPROMISED WATER
QUALITY INCREASES IN POLLUTION
AND MORE INTENSE WILDFIRES.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO THE
PACIFIC NORTHWEST EXPERIENCE AN
UNPRECEDENTED SEVERE HEAT STORM
LIKE NEVER BEFORE UNFORTUNATELY
RESULTING IN AT LEAST SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY DEATHS ALTHOUGH
WE CAN ESTIMATE. THE TRUE
NUMBER TO BE HIGHER BECAUSE
MANY DEATHS GO ON REPORTED.
THIS PAST WEEK IN CALIFORNIA
ONCE AGAIN EXPERIENCE THE
SCORCHING HOT EXTREME WEATHER
EVENT. HI MY CHANGES INCREASING
THE FREQUENCY SEVERITY AND
DURATION OF THESE HEAT WAVES
EXTREME HEAT IS A TRUE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS RESULTING IN MORE
DEATHS EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
AND IS ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING
FOR OLDER ADULTS AND THOSE WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS.
RECENT RESEARCH ALSO SUGGESTS
THAT SUICIDE RATES AND OTHER
FORMS OF VIOLENCE INCREASED
DURING EXTREME HEAT EVENTS. AS
A REPRESENTATIVE TO A LARGELY
DISADVANTAGED LATINO COMMUNITY
THERE ARE MORE THAN JUST
CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES THEY'RE
ALSO ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ISSUES AREAS THAT EXPERIENCE
EXTREME HEAT. OFTEN HAVE LARGE
EXPANSES OF CONCRETE LESS
GREENERY HIGHER DENSITY HOUSING
LOWER AVERAGE INCOMES AND POOR
HEALTH STATUS SENATORS DEATH
COULD BE PROVIDE DEATHS COULD
BE PREVENTED IF WE WERE TO
INVEST IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO MITIGATE THIS EXTREME
HATE. CONTINUED IN ACTION WILL
INCREASE HARDSHIPS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING DUE TO THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
WILL BRING EQUITY TO
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES AND
GIVE THEM A FIGHTING CHANCE TO
BEAT THE HEAT. I'M COMMITTED TO
THIS ISSUE AND HAVE SUBMITTED A
BUDGET REQUEST OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION. AND I'M WORKING
CLOSELY WITH LEADERSHIP ON THAT
REQUEST. TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL I HAVE ANDY GET WORKED UP
POLICY AND OUTREACH CONSULTANT
FROM CLIMATE RESOLVE. AND DR
MARK FIGHTER NICK REGIONAL
MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AT CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
MEDICAL CENTER. RIGHT LET'S GO
TO. MISTER WHAT THE FIRST MERRY.
FROM PLANNERS OF. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ANDREA HERE WHAT THE
AND I'M WITH CLIMATE RESULT
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ABOUT AB FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE THE EXTREME HEAT AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE PROGRAM.
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THREE KEY
POINTS FIRST. HE IS A BIG
PROBLEM AND THE SPEECH RESPONSE
THIS PIECEMEAL AND
EMPHATICALLY. THANK YOU. AB
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE ADDRESSES THE
GROWING PROBLEM BY. REQUIRING
COORDINATION OF EXISTING WORK
FROM MORE THAN A DOZEN FEET
AGENCIES CURRENTLY WORKING IN
PRIVATE- THE PROVIDES GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND COMMUNITY
GROUPS TO TAKE ACTION THANK
CREATE JOBS. THIRD PASSAGE OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE. TO THE
CROWN JEWEL TO PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIA. ESPECIALLY BLACK
THE BROWN AND OTHER VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES FROM THE INCREASING
THREATS OF EXTREME HEAT AS
WE'VE SEEN ON THE NEWS IN THE
PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS. THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY A DIVERSE GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
LABOR. PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. AS GROUPS AND
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ALAN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. BRAZIL
COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE ON THIS GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILL. THANK YOU NOW
WE'RE GONNA GO TO DOCTOR MARK I
FOR THE NECK FROM. ON THE MERCY
SERVICES CALVARY HOSPITAL
MEDICAL CENTER. HI I'M DOCTOR
MARKETER MAKE EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN PRACTICINGCLINICALLY
IN LOS ANGELES I'M ALSO A PAST
PRESIDENT AND CURRENT BOARD
MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WHICH IS
THE LARGEST CHAPTER IN THE
NATION. CAPTION MONIQUE BASED
ON MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN COMBINED
CARE REVIEWED MEDICAL RESEARCH
IF I BEGIN I THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK ON EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE EXTREME HEAT AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE PROGRAM. OUR STATE
IS GETTING HOTTER AND IMPACTING
OUR HEALTH RIGHT NOW THEY HAD
MY NUMBER SIXTEEN RELATED
FATALITIES WHICH SURPASSED ALL
OTHER NATURAL WEATHER EVENTS.
HAIL IN COMPARISON TO THE FULL
IMPACT OF INCREASED HEAT WHICH
IS GROSSLY UNDER REPORTED.
THAT'S DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO
EAT WE ARE USUALLY COVERED BY
SPECIFIC VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. MOST AT RISK ARE
ELDERLY LIVING ALONE PEOPLE WHO
ARE COMPROMISED BY CHRONIC
ILLNESS INCLUDING MENTAL
ILLNESS. LESS WORK OUTDOORS
EVEN ENDORSEMENT INADEQUATE
COOLING AND HISTORICALLY MORE
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER ANALYSIS OF LARGER
DATASETS HELLO MORE WORRISOME
STORY CAN ONLY INCREASE ACROSS
THE BOARD AND THE TEMPERATURE
RIGHT THAT OVERALL MORTALITY
INCREASE IN THERE ARE MORE
DEATHS OR CARDIOVASCULAR DEATH
THE CARD WHAT HEART ATTACKS OR
STROKES NUMBER ONE AND THREE
KILLERS IN THE WESTERN WORLD.
MORE RESPIRATORY ILLNESS JUMP
SURELY BASED ON THE TEMPERATURE
AND MORE OZONE A PREDOMINANT
MODEL YEAR CHEN IS PRODUCED AT
A HIGHER RATE AT HIGHER
TEMPERATURES POOR INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY MORE PEOPLE SHOOT
AND STAB EACH OTHER THE HIGHER
SEVERITY OF INJURIES WHEN IT IS
HOT OUTSIDE. THE STUDIES MAKE
IT CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT WE MUST
DO SOMETHING. ABOUT THIS
MELTING HEALTH CRISIS. CAN WE
DO. WE NEED TO PREVENT X. TO
AMBIENT ARE TAKE FOR LONG OF
TIME I COOLING ARE. CALLED
GROUP SHOULD TREAT PROBABLY
BILLION THAT CAN COOL AREAS
COOLER BUILT IN FOR WITH
REFLECTIVE GROUP GROUPS AND
OTHER MULTI BENEFIT PROJECT ARE
ALL EXAMPLES HOW GOVERNMENT CAN
INCENTIVISE PREVENTION
EXCESSIVE HEAT EXPOSURE. WE CAN
PREVENT HARM BY DISSEMINATING
CENTRALIZED IN CONSISTENT
MESSAGE ABOUT EXTREME HEAT. AND
HELP PEOPLE TO TAKE ACTION TO
PREVENT AND MITIGATE THE IMPACT
INCLUDING PERSONAL PREPARATION
AND KNOWING HOW TO ACCESS
PUBLIC RESOURCES. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE WOULD ACCOMPLISH
THIS BY COORDINATING THE
ACTIVITIES OF OVER A THOUSAND
STATE AGENCIES. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE OKAY SINCE THE
STATE EFFORTS TO GETTING THE
IMPACT OF DEADLY HEAT WAVES I
CAN'T THINK RECORDING
COORDINATION AND EFFECTIVENESS
IN OUR PREVENTION AND
MITIGATION RESPONSE IT. CHART
DANGEROUSLY WARMING ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN IN THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ONE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S
AND NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
EVEN ONCE THAT IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW. THE MESSAGE CARE LINE
NUMBER FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BUT
THE ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MORE INTO THE LAND CARE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JERRY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS A
MURKY REPRESENTING ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION NOR CAL AND
SOCAL CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER
ONE TWENTY MAYBE AIRLINES THAT
MEET. GOOD MORNING CHEN NUMBERS
SPEAKING DANGER BECAUSE THERE
WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTORS.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO. GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS
THEY'RE TALKING TO HAVE THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY SIX YEAH A LOT. LET'S
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
CHANGE GOING TO HAPPEN
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. YEP HELLO YES WE
GIVE YOU ONE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
ONE. YEAH KATHY THURMOND AND
RETIRED PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL
MUCH BUT THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT I HELPED DEVELOP
COMPARING CALIFORNIA FOR
EXTREME HEAT I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I NUMBER ONE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
BERSERKERS BURKE FROM THE AFTER
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
OF THE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GENOTOXIC PROJECTED BAZAAR
CANAL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH- THIS IS ON THE
SKINNER COMPLY ONE TWENTY EIGHT
MAYBE YOUR LINES I'M YOU. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
NATALIE NEXT MONDAY HAVE A
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION IN
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT. HE LINE
NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS LOUIS BLOOMBERG
I'M REPRESENTING THE ADRIENNE
ARSHT ROCKEFELLER FOUNDATION
RESILIENCE CENTER AT THE
ATLANTIC COUNCIL I WANT TO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REQUESTS FOR POWERFUL AND
ELOQUENT LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE- IN THE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE. MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DONNA THANKS REPRESENTING A LOT
CANCEL CAN BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARTICLE
SALAS TULARE COUNTY COURT.
THANK YOU TO ALL WHO ARE
PRESENT. AND AT THIS TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. OKAY I THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET'S GO TO- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES I AND
IS THERE IS ONE ORGANIZATION
THAT WE HAVE LISTEN OPPOSITION
AND IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE- ONE EXPRESSED CONCERN.
ABOUT THE BILL. MODERATOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. AND AT THIS TIME OF
THE DAY WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT GREAT ART LET'S BRING
THE BILL TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS DISCUSSION. BOB DYLAN
CASKEY YEAH I'M- I'M ON PAGE
TEN WITH THE AMENDMENTS AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS I THINK
THE FOURTH THE THIRD BULLET. IN
THE FIRST BOLD PARAGRAPH ABOUT
SEEKING TO MINIMIZE THE STRESS
ON THE ELECTRICAL GRID IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE'S SOME.
CHANGES THAT CAN BE MADE TO
CREATE A COOLER ENVIRONMENT
THAT DON'T. REQUIRE A GIGANTIC
AC SYSTEMS OF THIS MONTH SO
THAT'S GOOD AND SOME OF THAT
WOULD LEAD ME TO THE NEXT POINT
IS THAT. I APPLIED YOUR
ENTHUSIASM FOR SEEKING A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET AUGMENTATION. JUST SO
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE THE
SENATE WHILE EARLY WILDFIRE
PROPOSAL HAD FIFTY MILLION FOR
OPR TO DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
ANTICIPATING IN THIS. N.
UNFORTUNATELY THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE GOVERNOR DID NOT SEE THE
SAME WAY AS HE AS WE DID ON
THESE COOLING CENTERS IN THE
EMERGENCY- RETROFIT OF AREAS
FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING. EXTREME HEAT I
HOPE THAT THE ENTHUSIASM THAT
SOME PEOPLE SHOWN FOR THIS BILL
WILL TRANSFER OVER TO
LEADERSHIP. AND THAT THAT THERE
WILL BE A BETTER DISCUSSION
WITH EARLY WILDFIRE ACTION OUR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. ACTIONS
THAT THAT SENATE HAS
ARTICULATED COOLING CENTERS ON
BUT IS ON. HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
GET A THREE WAY DEAL. FOCUSING
IN ON THE THIRD BULLET ON THE
SECOND PORTION IS THAT HE-
COMMUNITY RESILIENCY CENTERS
THAT ARE CONSTRUCTED AND
RETROFITTED. IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
THAT WE'VE HAD AT LEAST ON THE
BUDGET SIDE HERE ON OUR COUNTY
FAIRS COUNTY COMMUNITY CENTERS
HAVING THEM YOU BE USE N.
AMERICANS WHO WERE CENTERS AND
ALL THAT DO YOU. ANTICIPATE
THAT SOME OF THE- ACTION WITH
YOUR BILL WOULD BE GOING THERE.
AS OPPOSED TO WEAR AND MORE
URBAN ENVIRONMENT THAT WOULD
HAVE TO DO- COOLING CENTERS AT
CONVENTION CENTERS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. OKAY YOU KNOW THE
TH- THE GOOD THING ABOUT THIS
BILL IS THAT IT ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DECIDE THAT YOU
KNOW IT IT. THIS BILL BENEFITS
BOTH URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES- AND WE WANT THEM
TO PLANNED FOR EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS- AND BE ABLE TO USE OF
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE-
IN ADDITION WITH WHAT WE WOULD
BE PROVIDING OF COURSE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES- TO MAKE
THAT PLAN HAPPEN IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. AND IN THE
CONSULTATION THAT OPR IS GOING
TO BE DEALING WITH- ACADEMIC
AND TECHNICAL EXPERTS THAT
INCLUDES ACTUALLY INDIVIDUALS
THAT SERVE ON THE AYE CARP WHO
MAYBE. ACTUALLY THE F. THE
EXPERT IN THAT FIELD YES OKAY
GOOD I'M OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
GREAT HOW SOMEONE I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE AMENDMENTS I
THINK AND I'M VERY PLEASED
ABOUT THIS BILL AND THEIR
CONTENTS SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUES WITH REGARDS TO. EXTREME
HEAT WHICH IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS. THIS OBSERVE THE
PROBLEMATIC PORTION OF THIS
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH. BUT THE GUARDS TO-
CLIMATE CHANGE SO. I'M TO MOVE
BY SUMMER CASKEY AS CENTER
GONZALEZ. I TO WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD SHE DOES HAVE TO SEE
REVISED SEEM TO HAVE REALLY
GOOD MOMENTUM ON THIS AND THE-
I'M AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED TO ADDRESS A LOT OF
WHAT AS A SENATOR A CASKET
MENTION- OF WHAT THE SENATE HAD
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF.
ADDRESSING THIS VERY ISSUE OF
EXTREME HEAT AND CLIMATE CHANGE
AND SPECIFICALLY I HAD A
QUESTION AS WELL WHICH I THINK
WAS- CLARIFIED ON THE THIRD
BULLET AND THE NUMBER FOUR
SPECIFIED THAT COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS CAN BE
CONSTRUCTED A RESPIRATORY
FITTED. TO SERVE THE PUBLIC
DURING EXTREME HEAT EVENTS- AND
I'LL TELL YOU I MEAN BEING IN
LOS ANGELES AS WE KNOW SENIORS
LIVING IN APARTMENT BUILDINGS
ALL BY THEMSELVES NOT HAVING
AND ANY REPRIEVE FROM THE HEAT
AND THE WORD LITERALLY IN THE
THICK OF IT RIGHT NOW. I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND STAND READY TO
HELP IN ANYWAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. YEAH. YEAH WE'RE JUST SIDE
BARRING ABOUT HOW THIS
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY HELD
HEARINGS ON THIS VERY TOPIC-
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO AND IT'S A
SIGN OF PROGRESS THAT WE'VE-
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO. GET
PEOPLE FOCUSED MEANS AND GET
THE SORT OF CONSENSUS BEHIND
YOUR BILL AND SOME OF THESE
OTHER EFFORTS THAT I CARP. SO
BOTH THE SENATE PROGRESS AND
ALSO I THINK IT IS A SIGN OF
HOW MUCH PEOPLE STERN AT.
BECOME MORE MORE AWARE OF THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
PROGRESS ON. I SUPPOSE YOU CAN
LOOK AT IT BOTH WAYS BUT- THE
BILL'S REMOVED HI WHAT'S THAT
YOU CLOSE. THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
SENATORS FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
YOUR INTEREST AND FOR THIS
DISCUSSION ESPECIALLY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI- YOU'VE BEEN
LEADING IN THIS AREA THROUGH
THE BUDGET THROUGH YOUR ROLE AS
BUDGET SUB CHAIR- I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO YOU CALIFORNIA'S
GRATEFUL TO YOU- THIS BILL IS
VERY TIMELY YOU KNOW WE JUST.
WE'RE GOING EVERY WEEKEND IS A
HEAT WAVE- WERE WARNING OUR
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT EXTREME HEAT
EVERY DAY EARLIER AND EARLIER
EVERY YEAR IT'S NO LONGER AN
AUGUST EVENT WE YOU KNOW WE
STARTED IN JUNE- IT'S GOING TO
GET WORSE AND CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO BE PREPARED AND SHOULD BE
LEADING- IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE PREPARED AND WERE-
PROVIDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED TO MITIGATE EXTREME HATE.
SO THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE BREAKS.
CONTROL THE CORAL. I ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB FIVE EIGHT FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
DALLY GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER STERN BY CASTING HI.
OKAY THIS THREE. OKAY LET'S
LET'S LOW HOLDER OPEN FOR THE
FOLKS AT ON BUT WE SHOULD
PROCEED YOU PROJECT YOUR BILL.
OKAY WE'RE HERE NEXT FROM
AUTUMN BURKE WHO'S HERE TO
PRESENT A. B. SIX EIGHTY ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IN YOUR CHEN IS
MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING SHARE AND
SENATORS. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
GLOBAL LEADER IN COMBATING
CLIMATE CHANGE OUR STATE HAS
LED THE WAY AN AGGRESSIVE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS ONCE
BEATING ARK ECONOMY TO BE THE
FIFTH LARGEST IN THE WORLD.
ALTHOUGH THERE'S BEEN GREAT
PROGRESS THERE IS MORE AND MORE
EVIDENCE SHOWING THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE NOT GOING TO
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE ONE I
REPRESENT WHERE THE FUNDING IS
MOST NEEDED. A JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT AUTHORED BY THE
STAFF FROM THE UCLA CENTER
FIRST ASSISTING ABILITY
COMMUNITIES FOUND THAT. THE
STRUCTURE OF OUR CLIMATE
INVESTMENT IS SKEWED TO BENEFIT
THE MOST AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES
IN OUR STATE. THIS HAS COME AT
THE EXPENSE OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AS THEY HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS ABILITY AND
RESOURCES TO ACCESS EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND INCENTIVES.
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING LEFT BY THE WAYSIDE AS
OUR STATE ADDRESSES CLIMATE
CHANGE. SB SIX EIGHTY HELPS
BRIDGE THIS GAP BY IMPLEMENTING
KEY POLICIES RECOMMENDED IN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S RECENT
REPORT. PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON
THE HIGH ROAD A JOBS AND
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR TWENTY
THIRTY. AB SIXTY WOULD REQUIRE
GIGI R. F. APPLICANTS TO USE
FAIR AND REASONABLE EMPLOYMENT
STANDARDS TO PROMOTE HIGH
QUALITY JOBS. INCLUDES A
PROCUREMENT POLICIES TO MAKE
SURE APPLICANTS ARE CONTRACTING
WITH OTHER RESPONSIBLE ENTITIES
AND PREVAILING WAGE FOR
CONSTRUCTION JOBS. NOW I'D LIKE
TO TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT THE GDR
OF BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME WHO
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
SOMEHOW TAKE AWAY FROM THE
PROGRAM'S EFFECTIVENESS BY
ADDING REQUIREMENTS THAT ENSURE
THAT WORKERS WHO BRING GIGI
ARE. PROJECTS TO FRUITION ARE
PAID WAGES AND PROVIDE BENEFITS
THAT CREATE A PATHWAY TO A
CAREER. NOT A JOB. WHAT IS A
PRIMARY PURPOSE WELL IT'S
PRIMARY PURPOSE IS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AB
THIRTY TWO ALSO MADE CLEAR.
THAT CLIMATE INVESTMENT SHOULD
BE DIRECTED TOWARDS THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR LEGISLATION
HAVE BEEN PASSED IN THE
FURTHERANCE OF THIS AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO FROM TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE REQUIRE THE G. G. R.
PROGRAMS MAXIMIZE ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS. AND COOK DIRECT
INVESTMENTS TOWARDS THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE. IN
ADDITION SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE IN
THE SAME YEAR ESTABLISH A
FRAMEWORK TO DIRECT EACH YEAR
IF INVESTMENTS AS THEIR
ASSOCIATED BENEFITS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THAT
BILL PROVIDED THE FRAMEWORK FOR
INVESTMENTS THAT CAN MEET
MULTIPLE POLICY OBJECTIVES.
ENHANCE THE ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. I CAN THINK OF NO
GREATER ECONOMIC BENEFIT THAN A
CAREER AT LEAST WAS STABLE AND
HOPEFULLY MIDDLE CLASS LIFE. I
SAT DOWN WITH THE CHAIR LAST
WEEK AND I APPRECIATE THE TIME
MISTER CHAIR. TO EXPLAIN TO HIM
WHERE ARE THE JOBS REPORT CAME
FROM AND WHY I HAD PUSHED SO
HARD FOR BOTH AND THREE FIFTY
AND AS A RESULT IN CAP AND
TRADE. I HAD AN EXPERIENCE
WHERE I WAS WITH US FOR A
SENATOR FROM I THINK IT WAS
NORTH CAROLINA'S NAMED CENTER
CARTER. AND HE HAD HIS DISTRICT
HAD COAL. AND WHEN THEY TOOK
AWAY HIS THE KANEMI AND HIS
COMMUNITY WENT DOWN AND HE
ENDED UP HAVING THE HIGHEST.
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES THAT THIS
COUNTRY HAS SEEN. AND HE WAS
ALMOST IN TEARS. HE WAS BAKING
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT L.
ENGINE UNDER UNDER ENERGY
INDUSTRIES. WHAT WILL MY PEOPLE
DO. WHAT JOB CAN I GET THEM HOW
DO I TRANSFER THEIR SKILLS FROM
WHERE THEY ARE NOW INTO THE
CLEAN A CONNIE. AND THIS GROWN
MAN WAS BEGGING. FOR A FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT HIS PEOPLE
TO WORK. AS SOMEONE WHO HAS A
DISTRICT THAT IS DIRECTLY THAT
I HAVE REFINERY IN MY DISTRICT.
MAKING SURE THAT MY COMMUNITY
CONTINUES TO THRIVE AS WE TRAIN
AS WE TRANSFER FROM A DIRTY
ECONOMY TO CLEAN ECONOMY. HAS
BEEN MY PRIORITY SINCE I HAVE
GOTTEN HERE. SO THIS BILL. SO
THAT'S WHERE THIS BILL CAME
FROM THAT'S WHERE THE REPORT
CAME FROM AND THAT'S WHERE THIS
BILL CAME FROM. THIS BILL WOULD
FURTHER PRIORITIZE APPLICANTS
THAT PARTNER WITH EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT TARGET RESIDENTS
UNDER IN UNDER RESOURCE TRIBAL
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAME REGION AS THE PROJECT.
THESE PROVISIONS WHICH ARE JUST
A FEW OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
PROPOSED BY THE CW DP'S
HIGHROAD REPORT. WITH PUT
PRINCIPLES OF EQUITY ON THE
FRONT END OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. RATHER THAN AN
AFTERTHOUGHT THROUGH A SET OF
SITES WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN
PLACE. I'D LIKE TO CLOSE BY
RELUCTANTLY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
WELL I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT INCREASED COST
TO SOME G. G. R. OF PROGRAMS
WITH THIS BILL I WOULD SUBMIT
TO YOU. THAT SACRIFICING THE
COST OF LABOR IS THE LAST
PLEASE WE SHOULD BE CUTTING.
ESPECIALLY NOW. THIS BILL WILL
LEAD TO MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
JOBS AND ECONOMIC INDEPENDENCE.
WE FIND ALMOST HALF OF OUR
FAMILIES AND CONSTRUCTION WORK
IN CALIFORNIA- AND ROLLED IN
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AN ANNUAL
COST OF THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THIS IS A REPORT FROM THE
UCBERKELEY LABOR CENTER IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THAT
BEING SAID I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FINDING A PATH
FOR THIS BILL TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON SIX EIGHTY TO MAKE SURE
THAT COMMUNITIES WHICH NEED
THESE CLIMB INVESTMENTS MOST
ARE NO LONGER LEFT BEHIND.
THANK YOU SUMMER I'M- YOUR
COMMENTS. SHE TOOK SEVEN
MINUTES APPRECIATE OUR
CONVERSATION FROM THE OTHER
DAY- OKAY LET'S GO LET'S NOW
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE AS WELL
AS IS ANYONE HERE PERSON WAS
EXPRESSIVE FOR THE BILL JEREMY
SPENCER. PERFECT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE MEMBERS AND FRIENDS-
THEY'RE- VERY GOOD DESCRIPTION
OF WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO AN
ANALYSIS- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT THE BILL-
37% A PERFECTLY WE SHOULD. WE
SHOULDN'T SACRIFICE THE COST OF
LABOR. WE SHOULDN'T SACRIFICE
THE COST OF LABOR. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT HUNTER
OF THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
AND I AND MANY OTHERS HAVE BEEN
SAYING ON MANY BILLS THIS
SESSION- WE'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT THIS THESE G. G. R. FUNDS
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE'S BILL
TO- FINALLY- PUT SOME.
PARAMETERS AROUND HOW THAT
MONEY IS SPENT TO ENSURE THAT
EQUITY IS- INCLUDED TO ENSURE
THAT- THESE PUBLIC DOLLARS GO
TO GOOD WAGES GOOD BENEFITS
GOOD JOBS THAT'S SOMETHING THE
LABOR MOVEMENT AND IN
PARTICULAR THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES I HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR DECADES- I IT'S THE
IT'S THE BASIS FOR THE
PREVAILING WAGE. IT'S THE BASIS
FOR THE LABOR MOVEMENT. AND WE
ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT HER
EFFORT TO- AS I SAID PUT SOME
PARAMETERS AROUND THESE DOLLARS
FOR THAT A POLICYMAKERS- HACKS
PAIRS THE LABOR MOVEMENT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND WE KNOW WHERE THIS
MONEY'S GOING. AND THAT IT'S
PROVIDING ACCORDIONS PROVIDING-
THE MIDDLE CLASS LIVELIHOOD FOR
THE WORKERS IN INDUSTRIES WHO
ARE BENEFITING FROM THE G. R.
I. FUNDS- AGAIN I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING A MEMBERS AND PRESS-
SEEMS LIKE THE BILL STILL
HEADING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
WE'RE HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY
AND WE- LOOK FOR THE CONTINUOUS
FORTY OFFERS MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU PATTERSON THIRTY
DURING OKAY OTHER FOLKS YEAH
OKAY. YOUR MEMBERS MIKE MONICA
TO BE HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL. IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS LIKE TO LAND A
REMARKS WITHOUT A MISTER SMITH.
GOOD PAYING JOBS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IS A
GOAL THAT WE CANNOT. GO FROM
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY ARE
THE PEOPLE ON THE PHONE LINES
ELECTED EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK OR MAKE
A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AB SIX ET. PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AND A LINE ONE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
TURN MEMBERS- JAMES DIRECTOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABOR'S ADMITTED BEING
SUPPORTED EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
THANK YOU. ONE ONE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TURN NUMBERS OVER FOR YOU I'M
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF BOILERMAKERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS NOT ON
COOPER FROM NIELSEN MARCH MARK
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA WE WERE MEETING THAT
OR IF AMENDED PETITION THANK
YOU. AND THERE ARE NO MORE KEY
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME MR CARE.
OKAY WHAT SON. WE HAVE TWO
FOLKS WHO WANTED TO CALL IN
OPPOSITION MARK STIVERS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. AND JOHN KENNEDY
FOR THE ROLE COUNTY REPRESENT
AS A CALIFORNIA. MUCH TECHNICAL
SORRY MARC. GREAT THIS IS MAX
IRISH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP- AND WHAT THE
AMENDMENT COULD ALLOW THE STATE
TO CONTINUE FUNDING
DEVELOPMENTS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE JUST
ACCEPTED. ONE OF OUR OPPOSITION
AND WE'RE VERY THANKFUL TO THE
CHAIR AND OFFICER TO GETTING US
TO THIS POINT THANK YOU. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ONE JOHN
KENNEDY NEXT. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S JOHN KENNEDY I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ARE MEMBER COUNTIES
OF EXPERIENCE THE LION'S SHARE
OF DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES OVER THE
LAST DECADE. WE FOUGHT FOR
YEARS TO GET SUBSTANTIAL STATE
INVESTMENT IN BETTER STATION
MANAGEMENT AND WHILE OUR RISK
REDUCTION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THANKS TO THE EFFORTS OF
SENATOR ALLEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD SB NINE OH ONE
APPROPRIATED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION INJURED EUROPE REVENUES
ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR FOR SELF
IMPROVEMENTAND WILDFIRES
PRODUCTION PROJECTS. THESE ARE
VITAL TO HELP THE STATE LOCAL
WILD CAN PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
SAFETY AND THE ENVIRONMENT. WE
OPPOSED EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
BECAUSE IT'S IMPACTS THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
THE STATE PREVAILING WAGE LAWS
AND REQUIRES USE OF A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS FOR PROJECTS
SEEKING OVER A MILLION DOLLARS.
INTO GIRAFFE FUNDS. WE HEAR
THAT REQUIRING PREVAILING WAGE
FOR VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROJECT WILL INCREASE THE COST
OF THOSE PROJECTS AND REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF ACRES THAT CAN BE
TREATED. AND REQUIRING USE OF
THE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT-
WILL IMPACT NEARLY ALL PROJECTS
FUNDED BY THE STATE AND IT'S
NOT CLEAR ORDER THAT THAT'S
THESE WILL AND RURAL AREAS
GIVEN THE BILLABLE LABOR.
SUPPLY AND AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
MUST BE PERFORMED. WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
OFFERED BY THE COMMITTEE TODAY
ON THE AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO
ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS SB NINE
OH ONE DID NOT CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATE SHOULD EUROPE FUNDS
FOR WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION.
THAT'S BECAUSE SOME SIGNIFICANT
HICK UPS AND PRODUCT DELIVERY
BUT IT ALSO REMOVES THE THOSE
PROJECTS FROM THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS. ONCE THE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDING THE
COMMUNITY ALSO TURNED GRANT RC
RC WILL BE PLEASED TO REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION TO AB SIX ANTI
THANK YOU. THANKS WE- ALL
RIGHT. ARM THANK YOU LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINES AND ONCE
EXPRESSED. OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT OR
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF BILL AB
SIX EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. MIDDLEBY ONE MOMENT. M.
LINE ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MARINO WHITE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM DUE TO THE RECENT
DATA AMENDMENTS WE WILL BE
MOVING TEN NEUTRAL POSITION
ONLINE OR COMMENT BUT THE
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR- WORK ON THIS
BILL TODAY. AND LINE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS RICHARD MARCUSSEN
FOR THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION FOR THE
PLUMBING HEATING COOLING
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS BUT WE DO OPPOSE THE
STATE MANDATE ON PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND LINE AT ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
ON YOUR LAWLER ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND WITH THE
AMENDMENT THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
AGREED TO TAKE WILL BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION THANKS.
WE HAVE ANY
OTHER COST. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MISTER CARE OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S BRING THE BILL BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION
THOUGHTS COMMENTS. CENTER STERN
THANK YOU MR- THANK YOU
SEPTEMBER FOR YOUR YOUR
pNOW- M. YOU HAVE REPRESENTED
YOU YOUR FOLKS- M. NOT JUST
LOCALLY BUT- CREATIVELY I
THINK- YOU KNOW YOUR STORY
ABOUT. THE SOUTH CAROLINA IS IN
NORTH CAROLINA SOUTH CAROLINA
YEAH- YOU KNOW WE'RE PETROLEUM
STATE WERE ALSO BIG CLEAN
ENERGY STATE VOTE BUT WE
CONSUME MORE PETROLEUM THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE ON THE PLANET
EXCEPT FOR THE U. S. AND CHINA
AND- AND WE PRODUCE A LOT TOO
AND PEOPLE WORK IN THOSE
SECTORS AND PEOPLE WORK IN
REFINING AND- PEOPLE WORK IN.
THE GAS INDUSTRY- AND I
ACTUALLY I LIKE TO THIS IS A
JOBS PLAN AND NOT A JUST
TRANSITION ANYMORE- I WILL SAY
I APPRECIATE THAT EVOLUTION OF
THE OF THE FRAME BECAUSE- I
DON'T THINK WE NEED TO
TRANSITION PIPEFITTERS OUT OF
PIPE FITTING JOBS. I DON'T
THINK WE NEED TO COLLECT OR
THAT LED JOB OR SHE MAY WORKERS
AS JOE THERE'S THOSE JOBS WITH
AND THERE'S A LOT WORK TO BE. I
THINK WE GOT TO GET PAST THAT
PERIOD I MADE YOUR LEAD IT WITH
THIS NOTION OF. CALIFORNIA PLAN
BEING A PAS AND PROACTIVE- I
JUST I HAVE TO SAY I AM A THAT
SEEMS LIKE TODAY'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO MAYBE IT TAKES
GETTING THIS BILL TO THE FLOOR
AND THE OTHER MEASURE WE JUST
HEARD- PREVIOUSLY THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE TO THE FLOOR BUT-
I. I WANT TO SEE THAT MOMENT
HAPPEN THIS SESSION WHERE. THE
WORKING PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE SAYING YES WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP PUSHING THE ENVELOPE AND
YES WE'RE GOING TO LOOK. FOR
NEW TECHNOLOGY AND WILLING TO
SAY WE'RE GOING BIG ON. NET
ZERO CARBON. NET ZERO EMISSIONS
AND- WE'RE INSIST ON HIGH ROAD
TO GET THERE. AND IT MAY NOT BE
THERE YET TODAY WHERE WE'VE GOT
ALL THOSE COALITIONS LINED UP
BUT- I FEEL LIKE WE'RE HONING
IN ON IT- AND- I'M HOPEFUL THAT
WE DON'T AND ANOTHER SESSION.
IN OUR SILOS IN OUR CAMP SO WE
KIND OF. COME TOGETHER THERE SO
AND I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BE
CRUCIAL TO MAKING THAT HAPPEN I
THINK THIS LOTUS MEASURES ACT.
OF A CRITICAL PART OF THAT
WHOLE PACKAGE AND THAT AND THAT
THAT PROMISE- SO. I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE I'M I'M
HAPPY TO. MOVE IT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- AND I JUST
WANT TO APPRECIATE- YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE CHURCH AS
WELL THANK YOU SENATOR. COULD
YOU MAYBE ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
THAT THE RULE COUNTIES HAD
ABOUT THEIR THE MINUTES I'M NOT
CLEAR ON THAT. THEY WERE FOR
ONGOING ENTRAPMENT FOR ANYTHING
DON'T. THEREFORE THE BILL. NOW
IT'S AN ONGOING PROGRAM IN
BECAUSE LIKE HE SAID- NINE ONE
DIDN'T MAKE IT AN ONGOING
FUNDING THAT IT REMOVES THEM
FROM THE BILL. IT WAS REMOVED
FROM THE BILL YOU SAY YEAH IT
REMOVES THEM FROM THE BILL
BECAUSE THEY DON'T AS OF NINE
ONE THEY DON'T HAVE AN ONGOING
SET OF FUNDING. I KNOW IT SEEMS
LIKE A TECHNICALITY- BUT I KNOW
YOU WOULD PREFER THEM TO HAVE
AN ONGOING. FUNDING BUT THEY-
DON'T AND SO IT REMOVES THEM
FROM THIS BILL. BUT WHAT ABOUT
LEADING LIKE HIGH SPEED RAIL OR
SOME OTHER THINGS WOULD BE IN
THIS BILL BUT THEY WOULD NOT BE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL. WHICH IS
WHY THEY REMOVED ONLY CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS INTERNET.
INCLUDED THANK YOU. I'M OKAY.
THE MOVE BY CENTER STERN- AS
THEY SAY- I THINK AN IMPORTANT
BILL AND I APPRECIATE. I THINK
I THINK A YOU KNOW WE GET TO A
PLACE WHERE. PROCEDURES IF
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE MOMENT I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS AND
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING- WITH
OUR COMMITTEE AS WE SOUGHT TO
GET THIS BILL TO PLACES MEET
YOUR CORE CALLS- AND SO WITH
THAT I. LOVE TO ASK YOU TO
CLOSE IT NO I'M AND SO THAT I'M
CLEAR FIRST THIS BILL AS A
PROACTIVE MEASURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE START THINKING ABOUT
HOW THE STATE MAKES.
INVESTMENTS IN OUR HUMANS IN
THE PEOPLE IN THIS COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I AM VERY CLEAR THAT
MY RELUCTANCE IS NOT. IS NOT
IN. AND GETTING THE BILL TO
WHERE EVERYONE FELT COMFORTABLE
ABOUT MY RELUCTANCE IS THAN
THAT- TRADITIONALLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE NOT
PARTICIPATED WHETHER ON ANY
LEVEL OF ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
HAVE STRUGGLE TO PARTICIPATE.
WHETHER THAT IS IN JOBS I DO
I'VE DONE TREATED- TTC'S TTC.
IT IS SUPER IMPORTANT TO ME
THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PARTICIPATE ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY ON EVERY LEVEL AND
WHETHER THAT'S AN EXECUTIVE
LEVEL OR CONSTRUCTION LEVEL.
THAT WE ARE THAT WE ARE
INCLUDED NOT. ARM AND WEATHER
IS ATION ARE THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT. BEEN ON EVERY SINGLE
LEVEL OF POLICY IN THIS AREA SO
I WANT TO MAKE SOME VERY VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT. I DON'T WANT
LIKE ME BE AN AFTERTHOUGHT
ANYMORE AND IT'S SOMETHING I
WILL I'VE CHAMPION SINCE I GOT
HERE AND I INTEND TO CHAMPION
UNTIL LIGHTLY. BUT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN ABOUT.
TEN I WANT I JUST WANTED I WANT.
THE DIFF IF MEMBERS HAVEN'T
SEEN IT AS PART OF OUR
CONVERSATION- THE AUTHOR. SEND
ME A COPY. THE LETTER OF- AFTER
MERRICK INFO TO. WORK FOR THEIR
BOARD WHO ARE RAISING A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT- EQUITY AND THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THEIR VOICES
WERE BEING ADEQUATELY ENGAGED
INCORPORATED INTO DECISION
MAKING AND I REALLY DO COMMEND
EVERYONE TO AN TO THAT LETTER I
KNOW A LOT OF US HAVE BROUGHT
IT UP AND- I CAME UP DURING THE
DISCUSSIONS OVER THE AIRPORT
APPOINTMENTS- ON THE SENATE
FLOOR. A COUPLE DAYS AGO- BUT-
BUT I THINK IF IT'S FORCED TO
REALLY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
OVER THERE AND I THINK WE DO
HAVE SOME A CONVERSATIONS AND
ALL OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
AGENCIES. UP AND DOWN. TO
ENSURE THAT. WE REALLY ARE
DEMOCRATIZING AND WHAT IS- YOU
KNOW AND ENDED IN ESSENTIAL
PART OF OUR GOVERNMENT TO WORK
AND ULTIMATELY AND- REALLY
ENGAGING ON THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT- THAT IDEALLY STAND MOST
TO BENEFIT FROM. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN AND THE CERTAINLY
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALL THE WORK I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN PLEASE
KALRA. ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN AYE ALLEN
AYE BATES. DALLY GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER STERN AYE
STERN AYE WHY CASKEY HI MY
COUNTY I. FOUR FIVE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE. IS
CENTER WARRIOR YES OKAY
FANTASTIC SEVEN AWARDS HERE TO
PRESENT A. B. NINE FIFTY. THANK
HM HE WAS. OKAY WE PROCEED WHEN
READY THIS IS ITEM SIX IN YOUR
POCKETS MEMBERS VERY BIG HEROES
RETURN MEMBERS HERE PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIFTY AND I
WANT TO FIRST SEE A PREVIEW THE
WORK ADDING WHAT ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE STAFF AND WE
AGREE WITH THEM OR TO ACCEPT
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT ON PAGE
SIX THE FINAL NOTICE IS AN
EXEMPTION AS DESCRIBED SO IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ORDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
TO IDENTIFY AND PRIORITIZE
ACCESS STATE OWNED PROPERTY AND
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE SUSTAINABLE
INNOVATIVE AND COST EFFECTIVE
HOUSING PROJECTS. HOWEVER
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THAT WHEN
A CITY OR COUNTY EXPRESSES AN
INTEREST IN PURCHASING THESE
PARCELS AGENCIES LIKE CALTRANS
MUST SELL THE PROPERTY AT FAIR
MARKET VALUE WHICH CREATES
ANOTHER OBSTACLE IN A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL COSTS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT SO THIS
BILL HELPS THIS ISSUE BY
AUTHORIZING A CALTRANS TO SELL
EXCESS PROPERTIES TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
LONG TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS OR FEEDING
PROGRAMS OF THE PROPERTY'S
ORIGINAL ACQUISITION VALUE.
THAT WOULD FACILITATE THE
TRANSFER IS STRATEGICALLY
LOCATED ACCESS LAND FOR THE USE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PROVIDES AN INNOVATIVE TOOL TO
ADDRESS OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS AND REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AND SPUR JOB GROWTH ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ON THE LINE TODAY
HAVE ONE WITNESS DANNY GOES THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALTRANS IN SUPPORT AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I BUT
WHEN THE TIME COMES THANK YOU
THE DESIGNER ALL RIGHT LET'S
HEAR. FROM MR YOST. HI GOOD
MORNING MA'AM. ARE ARE SENATOR.
HI MY NAME DANIELLE THE SYSTEM
DEPUTY TO. FOR LET'S. I
CALTRANS. RESPECTFULLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME HERE TODAY
AND- IT REALLY IS EXCITED TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL THIS YEAR
CALTRANS RECENTLY RELEASED THE
STRATEGIC PLAN WITH THE STATED
GOAL OF ADVANCING EQUITY
ELIGIBILITY IN ALL COMMUNITIES.
AND IT IS THROUGH THIS LENS
THAT CALTRANS RECOGNIZED AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT THE LAND ON
A PLAN TO SELL TO BETTER USE
HELPING OUR COMMUNITIES ADDRESS
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
MANY LOOK HAVE APPROACHED
CALTRANS ABOUT ACQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT ACTIVE PLANS. FOR
THE GOLD IS BILLS PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP LONG
TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BY
PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
USE OF CALTRANS PROPERTY. HI
THIS BILL ALSO ALLOWS THE LAND
TO BE USED FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS NAVIGATION CENTERS
PROVIDING SERVICES TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND IT
BILL WILL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. ALL RIGHT. I'M
THANK YOU LET'S NARROW. GO TO
FOLKS WANNA RATE REYES AND SO
YOU KNOW IN SUPPORT GERMAN.
THANK YOU A DIRECT MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE ARE A SUPPORT
OF AMANDA POSITION. WE'RE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS BUT LOOK FOR THOSE
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GREAT ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT MODERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
BILL AB NINE FIFTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF BILL AB
NINE FIFTY PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROGER DICKINSON OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
ONE I THINK YOU OKAY LET'S GO
TO AFFECTS ONE EXPRESS CONCERNS
OPPOSITION. WE ARE GERMANY
SUPPORT IF AMENDED- ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINE
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN THEIR-
NOW. THIS IS MARCH THAT RESULT.
TO SPEAK. I'M SORRY MARC. OKAY
I COULDN'T PRESS ONE ZERO
BECAUSE I WAS THE LEAD WITNESS
ON A DIFFERENT BILL THIS IS
MARK STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL WE UNFORTUNATELY
MUST OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE REFERENCE IS TO
SKILLED AND TRAINED LABOR AND
THEY WOULD HAVE A THE COST OF
THAT WOULD OUTWEIGH THE
PURCHASE PRICE DISCOUNT OF THE
BILL. IS ALTERNATE NEGATIVE TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I MEDICARE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
CAME ALLRIGHT LET'S BRING THE
ITEM BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION THOUGHTS- I WANT TO.
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
MOMENTS TAB AND THERE ARE SOME
OTHER MEMBERS AS WELL SENATE
ALI. THE SEVEN MEMBER I THE
ASKING TRANSPORTATION IF THE
PROJECT. PLAN WAS AVAILABLE TO
THE PEOPLE THAT ORIGINALLY HAD
IT IN A DOMAIN AND I DIDN'T SEE
THAT AMENDMENTS. ARE YOU PLAN
ON RECTIFYING THAT WITH THE
PEOPLE WHO HAD THEIR LAND TAKEN
FOR PACIFIC PURPOSE. NO SENATOR
I EVER RESPECTED YOUR COMMENT
THAT YOU MEAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE- BUT- WE COULD ALSO
GO BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
INHABITANTS WHICH WERE THE
NATIVE AMERICANS IF WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE ORIGINAL OWNERS.
THIS IS A NOW IN THE PUBLIC
PORTFOLIO AND IT'S OUR INTENT
WHERE WHERE IT IS RIGHT NOW WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO USE IT FOR
AN IMMEDIATE PUBLIC- PROCESS
IMMEDIATE PUBLIC TOP PRIORITY
WHICH IS. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. NO I'LL BE
OPPOSING BILLION TODAY. UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WHEN WE
EMINENT DOMAIN SOME IS PROPERTY
IT'S FOR A REASON. AND THAT'S
PRIVATE PROPERTY WHICH MAKES
AMERICA UNIQUE TO MOST OTHER
COUNTRIES- THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND- WE ONLY USED.
THE EMINENT DOMAIN PROCESS WHEN
IT'S GOOD FOR THE PUBLIC IN
THIS CASE IT SHOULD BE OFFERED
BACK TO THE PEOPLE OF THE LAND
WAS TAKEN FROM FOR THOSE
REASONS WILL BE OPPOSE IN THE
BILL. CENTER STERN. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU SUMMER FOR- BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD IN. EURO
APPROACH THIS YEAR VERY
CREATIVE AND PROGRESSIVE WHEN
IT COMES TO PUSHING THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PARADIGM
FORWARD- I WANTED TO ASK THOUGH
FOR YOUR SPONSOR I'M TRYING TO
I DID NOT GET A SENSE FROM THE
ANALYSIS- BUT WHAT WHAT KINDS
OF PROJECTS ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT- I'M I'M CURIOUS IF
CALTRANS AS A- A LIST OF
POTENTIAL SITES ARE PROPERTIES.
MAP AND INVENTORY EVEN JUST
EXAMPLES THAT I MEAN IN IN
DISTRICT SEVEN WHICH IS A HUGE
STRETCH IF CALTRANS LAND AND
SOME OF THAT'S MY DISTRICT BUT-
IN CENTER ALLEN SHARES THAT AND
MAY EVEN GO TO CENTER GONZALEZ
IS COMMUNITY THEIR NUMBER
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROPERTIES
TOO SO I I'M TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF. WHAT WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY LIKELY TO SEE IS THE
OUTCOME OF THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU CENTER- I'M AWARE OF
HUNDREDS OF PROPERTIES AT THE
DEPARTMENT TELLS US ARE
SUITABLE FOR RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD- BE
CONSISTENT AND ADJACENT TO
OTHER SITES THAT ARE. FOR THE
COMMUNITY- I'LL DEFER TO THE
WITNESS ABOUT MORE SPECIFICS I
AM ALSO INTERESTED IN SEEING
THE SPECIFICS OF THAT LIST. I
BELIEVE IT WAS LAST UPDATED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. MISTER
GUEST YET FOR MR YOST. YES- WE-
WE DO HAVE- A LIST OF
PROPERTIES THAT ARE OF HIGH
POTENTIAL TO- CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD TO THE PROCESS- FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- AND MAYBE-
MAY BE AVAILABLE FOR THAT
PURPOSE- I WOULD SAY IN
ADDITION TO THAT- THERE IS-
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SELL
PROPERTIES THAT WERE-
PURCHASED. FROM PREVIOUS OWNERS
BACK TO THOSE OWNERS OFTENTIMES
IN A PROJECT- PROPERTY TO BE
CONFIGURED- SO IT MAY NOT BE IN
THE SAME SHE PERFORMED GOD-
SOMEBODY MAY APPROACH THE
PREVIOUSLY. SOME ISSUES CAN CAN
WE SEE THAT LIST. YES
ABSOLUTELY SB GREAT I THINK YOU-KNOW IT'S A LITTLE TOUGH TO
VOTE- ON ON A BILL WHERE I
DON'T QUITE KNOW WHAT I'M
VOTING FOR- FOR THE SAKE OF-
FOR THE SAKE OF DISCUSSION DAVE
NECESSARY WILL MOVE ALONG AND-
GIVE IT A COURTESY VOTE BUT I
THINK BEFORE THE FLOOR
CERTAINLY BUT IDEALLY- THE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE IF YOU'VE GOT
IT TODAY EVEN THOUGH I'D LOVE
TO SEE IT- BEFORE TAKING A VOTE
HERE JUST BE GOOD TO KNOW. WHAT
WERE- WHAT WE'RE SIGNING ON TO
I THINK THAT THERE'S HUGE
POTENTIAL HERE AND I DON'T I
DON'T MEAN TO IMPLY THAT- THIS
THIS WON'T MAKE SENSE IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES I GUESS
MY- WHAT'S DRIVING MY CONCERN
IS IF WE'RE IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
SORT OF THE SUBPRIME PROPERTIES
FOR INSTANCE OR PLACES THAT
ARE. UNDER THE FREEWAY JUST FOR
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE- YOU KNOW SORT OF
HIGH OPPORTUNITY ZONES BEING
PRIORITIZE I KNOW THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT THE INTENT- I
THINK THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
CREATIVE THINGS WE CAN DO IT
CALTRANS PROPERTY SO- BUT I
JUST. BE GOOD TO PUT SOME MEAT
ON THE BONES BEFORE WE HAVE TO
ACTUALLY MAKE SOME FINAL
DECISIONS HERE DO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF TIMELINE THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT SOMETHING WE CAN
DO. EXPEDITIOUSLY MISTER YES. I
BELIEVE SO THAT THE MAIN ON
ISSUES MAKING SURE THE FIVE FOR
BOULDER YOU KNOW WHERE THE
PROPERTIES ARE- SO. THAT'S
SOMETHING I'LL MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WE DO ACTUALLY DISTANTLY
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. SIR
KASKI. SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT. WE ALL UNDERSTAND LEASE
MY UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
SEQUEL EXEMPTION IS HERE
BECAUSE BASICALLY WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL AS I'VE
READ IT IS THAT HE SAID THE
SALE TO THE CITY IS EXEMPT FROM
SEQUEL ANALYSIS SO WE HAVE WITH
THE SIR CALTRANS PROPERTY SO
THEY MAY HAVE HAD. WE DISAPPEAR
BICYCLE ELECTRIC BICYCLE BILL
OR YOU KNOW- FREE WAITED THERE
WITH THERE HAS BEEN AN
ENVIRONMENTAL. WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE ALREADY AND WHAT YOU
IN ALL THIS BILL DOES HE SAID
IT SAYS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NOTIFY THE CITIES THAT IF THEY
PUT A FIFTY FIVE YEAR. TERM FOR
AFFORDABLE THIRTY HAVE A THE
GROSS INCOME DOES NOT EXCEED A
HUNDRED TWENTY THAT THERE THAT
THEY USE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE THAT THEY HAVE SIXTY
DAYS AFTER CALTRANS. DOES THAT
TO SELL THE PROPERTY THAT
DOESN'T AFFECT WHAT SEQUEL
REQUIREMENTS MAY COME IN. AND
OTHER CONCERNS AT THE CITIES
HAVE ONCE THAT SALE IS DONE AND
THEN THAT. PROJECT COMES TO
LIFE IS THAT'S A SANITIZED
REDUCTION OF WHAT THE WHAT WHAT
IS THE SEQUEL EXCEPTION HERE'S
INTEREST THE SALE THAT IS RIGHT
SO THAT- TO HAVE AG CLARITY
THAT THE US SALE THE ACTION
THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS TAKING
HERE- IS CATEGORICALLY EXEMPT
FROM SEQUEL AND THEN YOU'RE
RIGHT SHOULD A- PROJECT WE
PROPOSE THAT HAS NOT BEEN
PREVIOUSLY COM- EVALUATED
UNDER. A PLAN OR A COMPARABLE
PROJECT AND THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO ADDITIONAL SEEK
REVIEW SOME SUIT THE I THINK I
HEARD SOME OF THE OBJECTIONS
OVER THE PROPOSED SKILLED AND
TRAINED LABOR PROVISIONS THAT
ARE BEING PUT IN THIS LANDUSE-
BYLAWS. AND BILL IF THAT'S TRUE
IF THE OPPOSITION'S TRUE THEN
NO CITIES WOULD RESPOND MY
GUESS IS WHAT WE WOULD HAVE
THIS BILL WE GIVE CALTRANS IS
OPPORTUNITY. BUT THEN CALTRANS
WOULD COME BACK AND SAY. WHAT'S
PLAN B. AND WE COUNTLESS. OF
CITIES AND UTILIZES AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE- A- PROCESS TO BE
ABLE TO GET AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION- BUILT IN THERE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN FOR
NINETY FIVE CITIES WILL TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS OKAY. VERY GOOD.
YES IF I COULD DO THAT ONE MORE
THING THE WAY I READ THAT
PROVISION ALSO IS IT'S AN
INTEMPERATE SENTENCE ABOUT
PROMOTION. THAT THE DEADLINE
YOU YOU SAID APPLY BEFORE BUT
NOW IT'S ABOUT PROMOTING THE
USE SO IT'S NOT ALSO A HARD AND
FAST MANDATE IN THE
LEGISLATION. WHEN YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION ON DRAFT
LANGUAGE- TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
WOULD IMPLEMENT IN A WAY THAT
IS SATISFACTORY FOR THEM AND
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH THE
TRADES AND BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AS WELL. GREAT THANK
YOU. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE SITES- HAVE BEEN DEEMED
OKAY FOR HOUSING I MEAN THIS IS
ALL THIS IS A PROCESS IT'S- I
WORKED OUT LOCALLY. THEY'RE ALL
SUITABLE FOR RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT ACCORDING TO
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
YEAH OKAY. OKAY. THE ADDAMS
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER STERN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE I
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
ARRIVA OKAY ALL RIGHT LET'S
CIRCLE THE VOTE COUNT-
CONSULTANTS CALDERON ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB NINE FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE BATES. DALLI
DALLI NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER. STERN BY EASTERN IOWA
CASKEY BY CASKEY I. STRAIGHTER
ONE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THAT OPEN FOR CENTERS INTERNET
ON. THANK YOU- LET'S NOT GO TO
SUMMER BERMAN WHO'S HERE TO
PRESENT HIS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
THIS AB. THIRTEEN FORTY SIX.
OKAY EVERYTHING IS THE ACTUAL
FIGHTING. SURE SURE. YEAH.
RECEIVE HONORARY MARC THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SANDERS. WHICH.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX WILL
REQUIRE ZERO EMISSIONS FROM NEW
SMALL OFF ROAD ENGINES SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA ON OR AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR BASED ON TECHNICAL
FEASIBILITY SMALL OFF ROAD
ENGINES KNOWN AS SOAR ARE
MAINLY USED IN LANDSCAPING
EQUIPMENT SUCH AS LEAF BLOWERS
AND LAWN MOWERS AND OTHER
OUTDOOR POWER EQUIPMENT
OPERATING A COMMERCIAL LEAF
BLOWER FOR ONE HOUR AND MINUTES
SMOG FORMING EMISSIONS
COMPARABLE TO DRIVING A TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TOYOTA CAMRY
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED MILES
OR FROM SACRAMENTO TO DENVER.
IN FACT SMOG FORMING EMISSIONS
FROM SORE ARE PROJECTED TO
SURPASS THOSE FROM PASSENGER
CARS IN CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR.
AMONG IMMEDIATELY IMPACTS OUR
ABILITY TO BREATHING CAUSES
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS TO
WORSEN. GAS ENGINES
ADDITIONALLY RELEASE BENZENE A
CARCINOGEN AND HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF ALTER FINE
PARTICLES WHICH CAUSE LUNG
CANCER HEART DISEASE STROKES.
ASTHMA AND OTHER RESPIRATORY
AILMENTS. GAS POWERED EQUIPMENT
POLLUTES THE AIR WE ALL BREATHE
BUT IT ESPECIALLY IMPACTS
LANDSCAPING PROFESSIONALS WHO
INHALE EXHAUST FROM GAS POWERED
EQUIPMENT FOR HOURS EVERY DAY.
FORTUNATELY THERE IS A FIX ZERO
MISSION EQUIPMENT THAT IS CLEAN
AND QUIET AND DOESN'T
CONTAMINATE THE AIR WE BREATHE
OR HARM THE HEALTH OF THOSE WHO
USE IT. AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
PHASES AND IS ZERO EMISSION
STANDARD FOR SALES OF NEW STORE
EITHER BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR OR
WHEN THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD DETERMINES IS
TECHNICALLY FEASIBLE WHICHEVER
IS LATER. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
DOES NOT DO. THIS BILL DOES NOT
BAN THE USE OF GAS POWERED
EQUIPMENT. EVERYONE CAN
CONTINUE USING THE EQUIPMENT
THEY HAVE UNTIL IT BREAKS DOWN.
BUSINESSES WILL NOT HAVE TO
REPLACE ALL OF THEIR EQUIPMENT
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS BILL
DOES NOT REGULATE CONSTRUCTION
OR FARM EQUIPMENT INCLUDING ANY
EQUIPMENT OVER TWENTY FIVE
HORSEPOWER WHICH IS FEDERALLY
PREEMPTED. PREOPTIC WOMEN
INCLUDES BRUSH CUTTERS IN
CLEARING SAWS FORTY CC AND
ABOVE IN WOOD CHIPPERS. THIS
BILL DOES NOT APPLY TO LARGE
CHAIN SAWS WITH ENGINE SIZE
OVER FORTY FIVE CC. IT DOES
APPLY TO SMALL CHAINSAWS IN
ADDITION AND THERE IS A SAFETY
PURCHASE EXEMPTION BUILT INTO
THE REGULATION SO CAL FIRE WILL
BE ABLE TO PURCHASE WHAT THEY
NEED FOR FIRE FIGHTING PURPOSES
AS WOULD CALTRANS OF THAT
REQUIRE GAS POWERED EQUIPMENT
FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE. THIS
BILL DOES APPLY TO SMALL
PORTABLE GENERATORS UNDER
TWENTY FIVE HORSEPOWER. HOWEVER
CARP HIS PROPOSED A LATER PHASE
IN DATE OF TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
FOR GENERATORS AND THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR THAT. AND LASTLY
THIS BILL DOES RECOGNIZE THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL APPLICATIONS BY
REQUIRING INCENTIVES FOR
COMMERCIAL OPERATORS. THE BILL
REQUIRES CARB TO FIND
INCENTIVES FOR ALL SORE WITHIN
EXISTING PROGRAMS. IN ADDITION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND I
ARE WORKING TO SECURE FUNDING
IN THE BUDGET TO CREATE A
DEDICATED INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR
SMALL LANDSCAPING BUSINESSES
AND SOLE PROPRIETORS TO
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
EQUIPMENT. ZERO MISSION
AGREEMENT SAVES MONEY IN THE
LONG RUN THROUGH LOWER FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS BUT THE
HIGHER UP FRONT COSTS OF
BATTERIES IS A BARRIER TO
ADOPTION ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE
WHICH IS CURRENTLY LOW. THAT IS
WHY THE FUNDING PIECE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS EFFORT.
SOME LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
INCLUDING SOUTH COAST IN SAN
JOAQUIN ALREADY RUN
COMPREHENSIVE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS
AND WE WANT TO EXPAND THAT
STATEWIDE. I WANT TO BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON FEASIBILITY. THERE ARE
AT LEAST EIGHT BRANDS THAT
PRODUCE COMMERCIAL GRADE ZERO
EMISSION EQUIPMENT IN EACH
MAJOR CATEGORY. AND EARLY
ADOPTERS HAVE SHOWN. THAT THIS
TRANSITION IS POSSIBLE. SEVERAL
LANDSCAPING COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA ALREADY OPERATE WITH
FULLY ZERO EMISSION EQUIPMENT.
AND LARGE INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS
U. S. C. THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA AND WESTSIDE UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
LANCASTER PALMDALE AREA. HAVE
TRANSITIONED TO CLEAN AND GREEN
LANDSCAPING. AND AGAIN THIS
BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE ANYONE TO
STOP USING WHAT THEY HAVE IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. IT ONLY
BANS THE SALE OF NEW GAS
POWERED SORE. I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE OPPOSITION FOR THE
DIALOGUE THEY HAVE HAD WITH MY
OFFICE. EVEN IF WE HAVE COME TO
DIFFERENT CONCLUSIONS. WITH ME
I HAVE BILL MCGAVIN WITH THE-
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. AND
DANIEL MADE WITH THE AMERICAN
GREEN'S ON ALLIANCE WHO HAS NOT
TAKEN A POSITION ON THE BILL
BUT IS HERE IN HIS CAPACITY AS
A SUBJECT AREA EXPERT. WHO CAN
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. LET'S
GO TO YOU BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX IT'S STILL EARLY IN
THE SUMMER AND THERE ALREADY
HAVE BEEN SEVERAL DAYS HERE IN
IN SACRAMENTO IN THE SOUTH
COAST IN THE BAY AREA WHERE THE
AIR QUALITY HAS BEEN SOMEONE
HEALTHY THAT WE'VE HAD. SPARE
THE AIR ALERTS AND THIS SECTOR
SMALL OFF ROAD ENGINES HAS A
SHOCKINGLY HIGH AMOUNT OF
EMISSIONS AS MR BERMAN HAS
POINTED OUT SO IT MUST BE
ADDRESSED IN ORDER TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORKER
HEALTH. THIS SHORT BILL HAS
BEEN WELL CRAFTED TO WORK WITH
THE ONGOING RULEMAKING PROCESS
AS YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THERE RESOURCES
BOARD HAS BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
REGULATING THESE ENGINES FOR
YEARS- THE RULEMAKING TO
STRENGTHEN THOSE REGULATIONS
NOW HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
WHILE YEAH IVE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN IT IT'S
MOSTLY. INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES WHO ARE THERE-
AND THERE'S LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTICIPATION
THAT RLEMAKING WILL HAPPEN
WITH OR WITHOUT THIS BILL- BUT
THIS BILL WILL HELP BY
INVOLVING THE LEGISLATURE
ADDING A STATUTORY MANDATE AND
CALLING FOR INCENTIVE FUNDING
TO HELP EASE THE TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION EQUIPMENT AND
THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU SHOULD THAT ALL
RIGHT LET'S NEXTCODE SO I GUESS
YOU OKAY WE HAVE THE WITNESS
FOR TECHNICAL EXPERTISE YEAH
AND I THINK- MISTER MAY BE
GIVING OPENING REMARKS I'D LIKE
TO MAKE OKAY. SIX FIVE PLEASE-
KITCHER ALLEN SENATORS MY NAME
IS DANIEL MAY I'M WITH I'M THE
FOUNDER OF THE AMERICAN GREEN'S
ON ALLIANCE KNOWN AS AGATHA AG
HELPS MUNICIPALITIES BUSINESSES
SCHOOLS AND NEIGHBORHOODS MAKE
AND DURING TRANSITIONS AWAY
FROM GAS POWERED OPERATIONS BY
EDUCATING TRAININGAND
CERTIFYING WORKERS WE ALSO
PROVIDE HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
AND ECONOMIC BENEFIT METRICS OF
THOSE ELECTRIC OPERATIONS AS
PART OF OUR CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM OUR PROCESS IS FACTUAL
AND OBJECTIVE. TODAY'S
COMMERCIAL GRADE EQUIPMENT CAN
PERFORM ALL BUT THE HEAVIEST
GROUNDS MAINTENANCE TASKS BAGGA
FINDS GAS EQUIPMENT IS STILL
NEEDED FOR A LIMITED SEASONAL
WORKLOADS IN INSTANCES WHERE A
LEAD TRICK IS NOT ECONOMICALLY
AND WORKLOAD FEASIBLE FOR THESE
SITUATIONS WE ALWAYS RECOMMEND
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
COMPLIANT FOR STROKE A QUICK
MINUTE. WE BELIEVE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX WITH AS THE
EXEMPTIONS ON CHAINSAWS FORTY
FIVE CC'S AND BRUSH CUTTERS AND
CLEARING SAWS FORTY SPECIES IS
ADDRESSING THIS. TO DATE ADDS
HAS CAN OVER SIX HUNDRED ACRES
OF SERVICEABLE PROPERTY TO
BATTERY ELECTRIC OPERATIONS FOR
ROUTINE MAINTENANCE
IMPROVEMENTS IN BATTERY
TECHNOLOGY HAVE HELPED US
ACHIEVE THIS BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS
PROCESS. IS FINANCIAL RESOURCES
EDUCATION TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION FOR THESE SIX
HUNDRED ACRES OF THE BENEFITS
OF THESE CONVERSIONS. HAVE
RESULTED IN IMPROVED CONDITIONS
FOR WORKERS REDUCTIONS AND OVER
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF
EMISSIONS AND SAVINGS ON
OPERATIONAL COSTS OVER TIME I
AM AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF NEEDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GREAT ARE
LET'S LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO WIN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONELINES- WITH
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER IN PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW.
MY NUMBER ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
DANIEL BROWN I MEAN HALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO
INSTRUCT THE PORT THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JACKPOT THREE FIFTY
THOUGHT VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU BAKER BERMAN.
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BRIDGE
PERSECUTOR ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE NINETY SEVEN THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PAUL GIVES ALL
THE SOMEBODY OFF THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MRS
ANDREW YEAGER RICHARD FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS ERIN RODRIGUEZ UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS REPORT
THANK YOU. SO I NUMBER SIXTY
THREE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JONATHAN ESCOBAR WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX. NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAKING SURE MY SECULAR
THREE FIFTY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX. AND AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. GRAHAM. LET'S
HEAR FROM THE LEADOFF POSITION
WITNESSES- WE'VE GOT- YOU LIKE
GARCIA FROM. WHO'S ACTUALLY
HERE REPRESENTING THE PORTABLE
GENERATOR MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION. THE MANAGER BRAVE
FROM NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
LANDSCAPE PROFESSIONALS AND
ALSO GREG NOT FROM THE OUTDOOR
POWER EQUIPMENT INSTITUTE WE
WANT TO. ASK YOU TO- REVIEW
RESPECTFULLY TO THIS TIMES AND
KEEP. THE OPPOSITION COMMENTS
QUICK SO WE CAN GET ALL THREE
OF YOU. LET'S START WITH YOU
I'M GONNA MEMBERS EAT. I THANK
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
GARCIA FOR THE PORTABLE
GENERATOR MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE TAKEN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND HAVE RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED
THAT PORTABLE GENERATORS BE
EXEMPT. FROM THE AIRBOARD
UPDATED SO REGULATIONS. IN THIS
BUILDING DOOR SPENT ON THE A OR
B. RULE MAKING AND IT'S
TIMELINE FAILED TO CONSIDER THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PORTABLE
GENERATORS. AND HOUSEHOLD OR
RESIDENTIAL LAWN AND GARDEN
EQUIPMENT. WITHOUT ANY. AB
FORTY SIX AND THEY ARE BEING.
IN WOMAN IN BANNING THE SALE
VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE PORTABLE
GENERATORS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO CALIFORNIANS TODAY. DURING A
LOSS OF POWER CUTS. I'M LIKE
LAWN AND GARDEN EQUIPMENT. BUT
TIME AND DURATION OF USE
PORTABLE GENERATORS IS OFTEN
NOT DISCRETIONARY. AND RELATE
THAT TO THE DIRECTION OF THE
POWER OUTAGE. CALIFORNIANS ARE
INCREASINGLY RELYING ON
PORTABLE GENERATORS FOR
EMERGENCY POWER NEEDS. TO POWER
GENERATORS RESPIRATORS AND
OTHER CRITICAL MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT. ZERO MISSION
PORTABLE GENERATORS ARE NOT A
VIABLE OR COMPARABLE OPTIONS
FOR EMERGENCY BACKUP POWER
NEEDS. AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTES THE PORTABLE
GENERATORS ARE CONSTRAINED BY
BATTERY CAPACITY. IT CAN ALSO
BE FIVE TO TWENTY TIMES THE
COST OF THE PORTABLE GENERATORS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TODAY. THE
COMMITTEE NOW. ADDITIONALLY
NOTES THAT THERE IS NO DISPUTE
THAT THE REQUIREMENTS BEING
CONTEMPLATED BY THE A. R. B.
FOR SOME SORT LIMIT COULD BE
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE IF NOT
DOWNRIGHT IMPOSSIBLE TO TODAY.
THAT REASON WE URGE YOU TO NOT
SIMPLY ENDORSE THE ARBY'S
REGULATION BUT INSTEAD TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE. THAT WILL BE
CRITICAL PRESERVE PORTABLE
GENERATOR OPTIONS DURING PS PS
AND OTHER LOSS OF POWER BANKS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK MR BERMAN AND HIS
STAFF FOR THEIR CLIMB THE TABLE
FORKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AYE OKAY
LET'S GO TO ENTER BRAG. NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU OUR MEMBERS- I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU BECAUSE
WHAT WE HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
ALL OF YOU OR YOUR STAFF AT
SOME POINT AND I AND I THANK
YOU FOR THE HEALTHY DIALOGUE.
ALSO LIKE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN- I THINK WE SHARE
A LOT MORE IN COMMON ON AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX AND RETURNED
DIFFERENCE- WE SHARE THE SAME
GOAL AS AN INDUSTRY IS WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN IS
NOTABLY PUTTING COURSE AND WE
WANT TO SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS.
THE KEY DIFFERENCE FOR US IN
THE THIRD BETWEEN COMMERCIAL
AND RESIDENTIAL I WATCHED HIM
TO FLEE THE COURT- AND APPLY
BUT TO BE WITNESSES SUPPORT.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
OF A PROCTOR SIX AND FOUR
BARREL. THANK YOU COMPANIES
MASS WE BELIEVE THAT COMPUTER
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE THIS
WHOLE TRêN. BACK LESS THAN
HALF A PERCENT OF ALL LANDSCAPE
COMPANIES. WHEN WE ARE WORKING
WITH AMERICAN COMPANIES ON
ADDITIONAL CARBON. WE WILL GET
A SPECIAL BLUE RIBBON TASK
FORCE SIX THE THANK FOR HOW WE
GET THERE. AND THE PROBLEM
FRANKLY IS THEIR INITIAL COST
EFFICIENCY COMPATIBILITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SPEND THE REST
OF THE TIME. BECAUSE AS MUCH
WARRANT SOME OF THE LARGER
EQUIPMENT AND THE COST FOR THE
HANOVER QUICK MATH SIMILAR BUT
WHEN YOU ASSOCIATE THE COSTS
FOR BATTERIES IN THE AMOUNT OF
BATTERY. THAT IS THE
SIGNIFICANT COST THERE'S ALSO
SICKENING COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
RETROFITTING YOUR SHOPS IN YOUR
TRUCK OF THE HANDLE THAT SORT
OF- ELECTRICAL LOAD. BERMAN
PHYSICAL STANDPOINT THAT IS
WHERE I DIFFER BASED ON THE
TECHNICAL EXPERTS THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH THERE IS STILL
SIGNIFICANT BRAND I'M SO SORRY
BUT- WE'RE WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF
YOUR SIDE OKAY I AM SO YOU CAN
BOOK YEAH. WE'VE GOT ONE OTHER
WITNESS TO TOTALLY UNDERSTAND I
APOLOGIZE AND I WANNA MAKE SURE
GREAT GET THE POINT I CAN'T I
WOULD JUST. RISK RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE SIMILAR BERMAN
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A TWO TO
THREE YEAR- DIFFERENT TIMELINE
FOR COMMERCIAL USES AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK SPECIALLY WITH
THE MEMBER BUT AT THIS TIME WE
WILL OPPOSE AT ADDRESS ABSTRACT.
THANK YOU UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU.
AND OBVIOUSLY WILL WELL I YOU
TO STAY ON. SO WE CAN ASK. IF
THE MEMBERS OF. OKAY LET'S.
LET'S LET'S GO TO GREG NOT TO
BRIEF. OUTLINE HIS CONCERN- ALL
THREE OF YOU WILL BE OF A FOR
FROM ASK. MR NOT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU IT IS
YOUR THAT IN A FIVE MANY
CONCERNS WITH AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX FOR MOST UNDERLINES
MODELING BASED ON A COLD CALL
TELEPHONE SURVEY IS FRAUGHT
WITH THE RELIEF THAT
INSIGNIFICANT OVERESTIMATE THE
PUT ME USE AND INTERNET SECTORS
EMISSIONS CONTRIBUTIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE RESIDENT ONE FIFTY
EIGHT REPORTED USING A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD GOLKAR SEVENTY
TIMES A YEAR FOR FIVE HOURS FOR
USE WITH TODAY'S TECHNOLOGY OPI
VEHICLE MANUFACTURED ESTIMATED
THAT THE RUNTIME OF TWO HOURS
PER CHARGE. WITH EIGHT TO
TWELVE HOUR RECHARGE TIME
PRESIDENT RESPONDED ARE BY
FIFTY FIVE SENIOR CITIZEN
BACHELOR RESPONDED BY USING
AMONG MANY OTHER PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT ONE WRITING MORE ONE
GOLF CAR AND TWO ELECTRIC
CHAINSAWS ALL SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
ALL FOR TWO POINT FIVE HOURS
PER TIME UNIT SECOND WRITING
UNIT. FOUR TIMES PER WEEK FOUR
DAYS A WEEK THAT'S RESPONDENT
REPORTED USING EQUIPMENT AT
LEAST TWELVE HOURS A DAY THIS
IS FILE REPORTS I'M OPERATE
WITH MORE THAN A HUNDRED HOURS
A WEEK. PRESIDENTIAL RESPONDED
SIX FIFTY NINE NINETY FIVE OLD
SENIOR CITIZEN RESPONSIBLE
USING CHAINSAWS MOBILE TIMES
HERE FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS FOR
USE A COMMERCIAL RESPONDED
NINETY ONE THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATIVE SECRETARY
REPORTED USING THE SCHOOL.
REPORTS TO THE SCHOOL USES
SMALL ENGINE POWER GENERATOR
EVERY DAY FOR EIGHT HOURS PER
USE. FINALLY MANY LANDSCAPERS
REPORT OPERATING FOR MORE THAN
FORTY HOURS PER WEEK PER
EMPLOYEE. VENDOR ONE NINETY
EIGHT REPORTED USING OPEN
SEVENTY EIGHT HOURS PER WEEK
PER EMPLOYEE- RESPONDED OF THE
TWELVE REPORTS ARE PRETTY OPEN
MORE THAN FIFTY HOURS PER WEEK
PER EMPLOYEE WELL SERVICING
SIXTY CUSTOMERS. AND RESPOND
THE CONTAINER PORT OPERATE
WITHIN NO MORE THAN SEVENTY
HOURS PER WEEK PER EMPLOYEE
WILL SERVICE THE THIRTY
CUSTOMERS THESE RESPONSES ARE
NOT RESOLVED THE I SURVEYED THE
LANDSCAPE BECAUSE IT MAINTAINS
THE GROUND INTEL. PASADENA
CALIFORNIA WANT TO CALIFORNIA
AT THE COMMUNITIES THE
LANDSCAPER REPORTEDLY BATTERY
POWER WRITING MORE THREE POINT
FIVE DAYS PER WEEK FOR FIVE
HOURS FOR USE FOR THREE FOR
THREE YEARS THAT TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY HOURS. ONE
OF THE I INVESTIGATED THE
UNITIVE FOUNDED THE OUR MERE
READING WITH ELEVEN HUNDRED
HOURS- THIS SURVEY WHAT WE
DESERVE A RESPONSE THE
LANDSCAPER OVERESTIMATE THE USE
OF EQUIPMENT BY MUCH MORE THAN
DOUBLE. THAT RELATE BABY
THIRTEEN FORTY. SECTION ONE
POINT COMPARE SOURCE LIKE. IN
THE PAST YEAR VEHICLE WAS WHICH
IS A INACCURATE. OVER US RECORD.
OF THE STORE WE- WITHOUT AN
ACTOR UNDERSTANDING OF CORE
MISSION BEEN REPORT PROPOSAL
BAN SO ARM. INVITE THE FOR THE
CLEAN AIR WHICH CAL. Y. WITH
THE- UNIQUE AND MISTER.
REGULATION ALLOWING SERVE CARDS
OR MULTI MORE THAN. YEARS TO
DEVELOP THE CANNOT BE CORRECTED
IN THE TIME LINE FOR. IN THIS
BILL. INTEREST PORTS REASON
REGULATE WHICH NEED IT AND THAT
KALRA THIRTEEN SIX IN THE
ABSENT OF AN ACTOR. REFLECTING
CONTRIBUTION. AND WITHOUT.
PROVEN SOLUTIONS ACROSS THE-
RANGE OF SORRY WE GOT A WE GOT
IT IN YOU LIFE THERE ARE. I'M
VERY BOTH OPI. EIGHT THIRTEEN
FORTY THANK YOU SHARE OKAY. I.
BUT YOU KNOW JUST WANTING FOLKS
IF YOU MORE CLARITY. I WAS A- I
YOU KNOW I THINK WE SHOULD THE
TRY TO WE'RE GOING TO THESE OF
STAR ONLY HAVE TO LEAVE
OPPOSITION. TO GIVE MORE TIME
EACH IN THE- IT REALLY DOES PUT
THE LAST FIRST IT DOESN'T. OKAY
BUT FOLKS CAN CERTAINLY UPON OF
THE THREE. LEAD OPPOSITE
WITNESSES IF YOU LOOK ARSIA-
FROM THE PORTABLE CHEN MASTER.
AS HE- AND WE PRAY FOR THE
NATIONALS. WHEN FOR. OR NOT.
FROM THE OUTDOOR POWER OF
INSTITUTE IN THE COURSE OF GOT
OUR TO. THE WITNESS HERE IN
SUPPORT FROM COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR AND THE AMERICAN
GREEN'S OWN ALLIANCE SO. WITH
THAT BEING SAID IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES WHO WANTS TO
EXPRESS. CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE'LL. WE
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO THEIR OWN NOW. ONE
MOMENT OF THE DAY WE HAVE
PEOPLE QUEUING UP AT THE MOMENT.
MY NUMBER ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS AFRIKA MORTGAGE
FOR THE WORKING LANDSCAPE
NETWORK AND ALSO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION MISTER
PROFESSIONALS OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL THE- VAST MAJORITY OF
SMOKERS ARE LATINO AS WELL AS
ONE OF THE SMALL BUSINESS. BUT
OUR- THERE ARE SMALL THE SMALL
GARDENING BUSINESS THIS BILL
WILL NEGATIVELY AFFECT THOSE
ORDERS AND FORCE THEM TO BUY
THEIR EQUIPMENT AND STATE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA TAX REVENUE
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING REBEKAH
BACK AND ON BEHALF OF THE FAR
WEST EQUIPMENT DEALERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU KNOW. AND AT THE TIME OF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
CAN QUEUE. OKAY GREAT OKAY SO
NOW BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND THOUGHTS AND
DISCUSSIONS GOING TO SENATORS
STERN. THANK YOU MR- I DON'T
THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THE MEASURE FORWARD-
AND ALWAYS DILIGENCE ON THIS
MATTER AT THE- AND I WANT ONE
ISSUE I WAS HOPING TO GET-
MAYBE SOME TECHNICAL FEEDBACK
ON OR FROM YOUR EXPERT- YOUR
SPONSOR- WE DIDN'T TALK- IN
QUANTIFIED TERMS ABOUT SOME OF
THE HEALTH IMPACTS THAT OUR
LANDSCAPE PROFESSIONALS ARE IN
DURING BUT ALSO. THAT YOU KNOW
WITH THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT IMPACTS OF PORTABLE
GENERATORS- AND HOW CRUCIAL
THEY CAN BE- TO HOMEOWNERS
WE'VE HAD MORE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS IN MY DISTRICT
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT THE RECENT
DATA WE'VE BEEN SEEING IS THAT-
MISUSE OF THOSE EYES ARE DEEP
EITHER DIESEL OR GAS POWERED
GENERATORS ACTUALLY. VERY
DANGEROUS AND EVEN DEADLY I
THINK CONSUMER REPORTS THE WHAT
I JUST SAW WAS IDON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S MORE RECENT DATA BUT
FROM 200-052-2017 NINE HUNDRED
PEOPLE DIED. OF CARBON MONOXIDE
POISONING AND THE THOUSANDS OF
BEEN POISONED- ON TOP OF THAT
AND YOU KNOW I KNOW THROUGH
THESE P. S. P. S. INCIDENTS
WE'VE HAD A FEW DEATHS-
EXPECTANT MOTHER IN TAX SHOULD
BE- LAST YEAR- AND AT A
PERSONAL LEVEL YOU KNOW WHEN
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THESE P. S.
P. S. INCIDENTS. OR WHEN- YOU
KNOW WHATEVER THAT THAT-
LANDSCAPING EQUIPMENT IS BREAK
BEHIND MY HOUSE THAT'S GOING.
WHEN MY WIFE'S OUTSIDE SHE
SEVEN HALF MONTHS PREGNANT SHE
LIKES THE SOUND OF YEAH THE
NEIGHBORHOODS BUZZING PEOPLE
ARE WORKING YOU KNOW THERE'S
SORT OF. NO NO CONCERNED ABOUT
EVEN NOISE OR PEOPLE DOING
THEIR JOBS BUT- THE NOTION OF
BENZENE AND CARBON MONOXIDE
GOING INTO THE LUNGS OF
PREGNANT WOMEN AROUND
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH QUANTIFY LIKE. WHAT OTHER
DATA BESIDES THAT TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BUT- I THINK
THERE'S A THERE'S A CRITICAL
CASE TO BE MADE ON THAT THE
HEALTH SIDE OF THIS LEGISLATION
NOT JUST. IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
TECHNOLOGY- AND I'M REALLY
ENCOURAGES THE WITH THE
INDUSTRY'S COMING UP WITH I
DON'T SEE ANY LACK OF CAPITAL
BY THE WAY COMING IN EITHER I
THINK PORTAL GENERATOR SALES
REP 2000% I THINK SINCE OUR PS
PS STUFF BEGINNING CALIFORNIA
SO THERE'S PLENTY CAPITAL I
KNOW THERE'S THE KNOW HOW
WITHIN. WHETHER IT'S GENERAC-
YOU KNOW- SOME OF YOU KNOW GET
YAMAHA KAWASAKI THESE ARE THESE
ARE SMART COMPANIES I THINK WE
CAN FIGURE THIS STUFF OUT BUT-
JUST DIDN'T KNOW IF YOU YOU ARE
YOUR SPONSORS WANTED LENT ANY
INSIGHT ON THE- THE NEAR TERM
HEALTH IMPACTS ON EITHER OF
THOSE ISSUES YES THANK YOU
CENTER FOR. FURTHER COMMENTS IN
QUESTION AND- YEAH LIKE YOU
SAID THIS PLAN CAPITAL THEY
ALSO HAVE MORE TIME ON THE
GENERATOR FRONT BECAUSE CARP IS
PLANNING TO. HAVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR
GENERATORS BE TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT- SO THAT THAT SEVEN YEARS
FROM NOW AND WE KNOW THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY ALREADY EXISTS
THAT'S A LOT OF TIME TO IMPROVE
IT AND TO BRING THE COST DOWN.
TO HAVE A BE MORE COST
COMPARABLE. WITH THE GAS
POWERED ALTERNATIVES- THE QUICK
TOUCHING ON GENERATORS THE BILL
APPLIES TO SPARK IGNITION
PORTABLE GENERATORS UNDER
TWENTY FIVE HORSEPOWER- SO
LARGE STATIONARY GENERATORS AND
DIESEL GENERATORS ARE NOT
SUBJECT SUBJECT TO THIS BILL-
SO THEY YOU KNOW FOR PEOPLE
STILL CAN USE THOSE IF THEY
NEED TO YOU MADE A GOOD POINT
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN. IF YOU
THE MISUSE THEM AND THERE CAN
BE DEADLY HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
TO THAT END OF THE SMALLER ONES
AS WELL. THE ZERO EMISSION
GENERATORS HAVE A HIGHER PRICE
NOW WHICH IS WHY THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS OF A LATER PHASE
AND A LIKE I MENTIONED TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT- AND- GOT A
TALKING POINT THAT I HAVE REAL
QUICK IS EXPOSURE TO
CARCINOGENIC THIS APARTMENT
CLOSE TO WILL NOW. NOT BE PART
OF MY CLOTHES- X. TO CAR.
AIRPORT AND HIGH LEVELS OF.
FINE PARTICLES THAT CAUSE
ASTHMA ANOTHER US- TESSA'S. TO
BE FORTY TIMES HIGHER- FOUR
TIMES HIGHER THAN A TO- EXCUSE
ME. TESTS HAVE SHOWN TO BE
FORTY TIMES HIGHER. IF YOU'RE
NEAR A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
MODEL LEAF BLOWER. THEN IF
YOU'RE NEAR A BUSY INTERSECTION-
AND THEN TO THAT JUST GIVES YOU
A SENSE OF THE- YOU KNOW
EXACTLY HOW THE HEALTH IMPACTS.
I CAN BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU TO THE TECHNICAL AND EXPERT
ON IT JUST JUST VERY BRIEFLY IF
I MAY MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK
CENTER STERN YOU JUST MADE AN
EXCELLENT CASE FOR WHY WE NEED
TO UPGRADE THE STANDARDS AND
MAKE THE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION EQUIPMENT. AND AS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE ZERO EMISSION
GENERATORS AVAILABLE FUEL CELLS
BATTERY POWERED WHEN YOUR
GENERATORS AND WE NEED TO
ACCELERATE THAT TRANSITION SO
THAT THOSE ARE ACCESSIBLE TO
EVERYBODY. AND THIS BILL WILL
HELP TO DO THAT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. HI I WOULD ALSO JUST SAY
I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE ANY I
DON'T THINK ANY SENATE CO
AUTHORS ON THIS MEASURE SO IN
ADDITION TO MOVING THE MEASURE.
I WANTED GOING TO BE FIRST
THANK YOU THINK AT LEAST JUMP
ON I'LL BE SECOND TO THE CHAIR
HOWEVER YOU WANT BUT IF THEY
YOU CENTER AND THREE IF WE MAKE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL WE WILL-
WILL DEFINITELY ADD ON CYNICAL
AUTHORS VERY GOOD. APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU- MISTER MADE MIGHT
HAVE. A POINT TO MAKE. THANK
YOU- JUST FOR THE RECORD. AG'S
IS NEUTRAL ON THE BILL- BUT-
WE- ARE. FACT IT WAS CREATED.
BY GAS PROFESSIONALS FOR GAS
PROFESSIONALS. TO MAKE PRUDENT
CHANGE. AND WE ARE HERE JUST TO
GIVE YOU THE ROTH EXES AND OHS.
OF WHAT ADDSIT HAS
ACCOMPLISHED. AND WE ARE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE. FURTHER
DATA. ON ON WHAT WE'VE DONE-
ANYTIME YOU CAN CALL ON US AND
WE WILL JUST GIVE YOU THOSE
ROTH. EX'S AND OH'S THANK YOU.
NAME IS MADE. OKAY I KNOW WE
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS FROM
SENATOR DOLLY THAT'S WHAT WE.
THE MEASURE CARE GOOD TO SEE
YOU SENATE MEMBER- FIRST OFF I
WANT TO SAY THAT- I'M NOT GOING
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL A
CIGARETTE THAT. I DID NOT SEE.
THAT I'M NOT SURPRISED BY THAT
AS IT'S WHAT I WANT WHEN I WANT
TO SEE I HAVE LOTS OF PERSONAL
I WANTED THEIR RESUME ONE OF
THE FIRST THE WITNESS THAT TED
WENT ON REALLY FAST I COULDN'T
CATCH ALL THE DETAILS. BUT
THERE HAS BEEN SOME TALK ABOUT
HOW THE DATA WAS GATHERED COULD
YOU RESPOND TO THAT FIRST OFF
YES MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
THAT THE DATA- WITH SOME FROM A
PHONE SURVEY- THAT WAS A
COMPONENT OF CARBS TWENTY
TWENTY INVENTORY MODELING AND
THAT CARBON VAULT INDUSTRY TO
ENGAGE WITH DATA AND IDENTIFY
OUT LIARS AND THE DATA THE DATA
IS CURRENTLY WHAT WE HAVE
INDUSTRY HASN'T PROVIDED ANY
ALTERNATIVE DTA- SOURCE OF
EMISSIONS- SO- YOU KNOW VERY
OPEN TO IT TO. DIVING INTO THAT
MORE WITH INDUSTRY IF THEY WANT
TO PROVIDE SOME ALTERNATIVE
DATA FOR US TO LOOK AT WELL I
DON'T THINK THAT WE'RE MAKING
SOME REALLY- THIS ISN'T THIS IS
A BIG PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
THINK THIS IS GONNA BE VERY.
BURDENS ON SPECIALLY PEOPLE
WITH WHO ARE EXPERIENCING. IN A
PUBLIC CAR SAFETY SHUT OFFS-
AND I DID I JUST GOOGLE WHY WE
WERE SITTING HERE- TWENTY FIVE
HORSEPOWER IS FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE CC SO YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT FORTY SPECIES
WHICH IS A VERY SMALL.
GENERATOR WHICH CAN YOU KNOW
KEEP YOUR- THE FRAZIER YEAH
YOUR FRIDGE RATER YOUR VIEW OF
YOUR LIFE- YOUR THE ERROR
MONITORING IF YOU'RE DIFFER ON
THE ALIVE SUPPORT WORKS THEIR
STUFF SO I WANTED TO SHARE I
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T
A- NOT WELL THOUGHT OUT YET I
THINK WE NEED MORE DATA I THINK
THE DATA IS A LITTLE BIT SKEWED
I THINK THAT- MORE I'D LIKE TO
SEE MORE O A CARROT AND A
STICK I FOR CHRISTMAS BY
MYSELF- ACTUALLY A WHOLE SET OF
CORDLESS. IMPACT WRENCHES I
NORMALLY USE AIR DRIVEN WHICH I
DID RUN A COMPRESSOR. STAY IN
THE HOSE OUT AND THEY'RE
AWESOME THIS STUFF THE
TECHNOLOGY IS REALLY AMAZING
AND I GOT A POLL SAW- TO TRIM
THE TREES ON THE WAY INTO MY
FARM SO MANY CLIP IT DOESN'T.
GET THE MAYOR'S TORN OFF OF IT
AND- IT WORKS GREAT. BUT WHEN
I'M OUT IN THE FIELD. AND I
HAVE TO GO TWENTY MILES. EITHER
WAY BACK AND FORTH TO THE RANCH.
I HAVE AN INVERTER. IT'S A PLUG
IN THE IT'S IN YOUR PICK UP
RIGHT AND YOU CAN CHARGE YOUR
BATTERY SO I HAVE TO START TO
PICK UP OF MY BATTERY GOES BAD
DAD TO. CHARGE MY IMPACT RICH
SO I THINK THERE'S I THINK MORE
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS A STICK
WHY DON'T WE JUST INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO CONVERT OVER WHO MAKE
CAN MAKE THAT CHOICE INSTEAD OF
SAYING HEY YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO BUY THESE PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO YEARS. PRICE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THE FIRST PHASE
NOT GENERATORS ARE OUT FURTHER
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S THE
PROBLEM WITH THE LEGISLATION
FOR ME IS THAT WHERE
ENFORCEMENT WE'RE ALLOWING
THEIR BOARD WHICH BY THE WAY I
SPOKE EARLIER ON AND OTHER BILL
WE HAD A NEAR THE AIRPORT WE
JUST CHANGE THE WHOLE BOARD.
THE BEHIND IT WITH THE SENATE
JUST APPROVED. NEW MEMBERS
THEIR BOARD THAT'S BECAUSE THE
LAST. LORD WAS A PERFORMING AT
THE AT THE LEVEL WE WANTED TO
LET TO PERFORM AND WE SEE THAT
A LOT HERE WHEN THE- HIGH SPEED
TRAIN DOESN'T WORK WE JUST
REPLACE THE PERSON WHO'S IN
CHARGE AND YOU KNOW THE LAST
GUY WASN'T OUR LAST GROUP
WASN'T. THE ONE THAT DID IT AND
THEN WHEN THAT DOESN'T WORK WE
JUST CONTINUE TO DO WHAT.
GOVERNMENT DOES IS REPLACE IT
AND BLAME IT ON THE- OTHER GUY
THAT'S NOT HERE ANYMORE. AND I
DON'T LIKE THAT PROCESS I'D
ACTUALLY LIKE TO DO SOMETHING
THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND GET A GOOD
POLICY OUT. SO IN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AS GONNA DEFINITELY
IMPACT A LOT OF PEOPLE. GONNA
IN IMPACT A- SMALL MINORITY
LANDSCAPERS IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT. I'M ALWAYS GLAD TO HEAR
THAT US GUYS INACCURATE EXEMPT
THANK YOU FOR THAT- BUT WON'T
NEED LONG WHEN THEY'RE BORED
COMES AFTER THAT GUYS. JUST
LIKE THEY'RE DOING WITH OUR-
FARMING EQUIPMENT THAT WASN'T
PART OF THE TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGE. SO I'M PUTTING OUT A
LOT OF CITIES THINGS HERE BUT I
JUST ENSURE THAT I DON'T I
DON'T THINK THIS IS REALLY
COOKED WELL I THINK THERE'S A
LOT THINK I THINK THAT DATA
NEEDS TO BE ONFIRMED NOT JUST
A PHONE SURVEY THAT'S THAT'S-
PRETTY GENERIC. WE NEED TO HAVE
REAL RAW DATA AND THE
OPPOSITION POINTED OUT THAT
THEY ACTUALLY FOLLOWED UP ON
SOME OF THE PHONE DATA AND-
FOUND THAT. AT LEAST IN THEIR
SIDE OF IT WASN'T AT THAT
WASN'T. REPORTED ACCURATELY SO
WE'RE MAKING A BIG DECISION IN
CALIFORNIA. ON I THINK NOT A
LOT OF GREAT INFORMATION. SO IF
YOU COULD RESPOND TO THOSE I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
SENATOR- AND- IT'S- THE FARM
EQUIPMENT AND- THE FIREFIGHTING
EQUIPMENT. IS EXEMPT UNDER
FEDERAL LAWSUIT SO CAR CAN'T
COME. FOR YOUR FOR YOUR FARM
EQUIPMENT- THANK GOD AND THIS
IS A CHANGE IN IN FEDERAL LAW.
BUT I ALSO JUST WANT TO YOU
KNOW RE EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
DOESN'T TAKE ANYTHING AWAY
FROM. FROM PEOPLE SO IF YOU
HAVE GAS POWERED EQUIPMENT- YOU
CAN CONTINUE TO USE THAT. UNTIL
YOU KNOW DO THE REPAIRING IT
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
REPAIR IT ANYMORE AND UNTIL
THIS IS AND OF USE AND SO. YOU
CAN KEEP ON USING THAT POST THE
FIRST POSSIBLE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE WOULD BE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR OR LATER
DEPENDING ON ON CARDS-
TECHNICAL FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY DECIDE.
TO PUSH THAT BACK LATER LIKE
THEY'VE ALREADY SAID THEY WILL
FOR THE GENERATORS WHICH WILL
BE TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. AT THE
EARLIEST AND SO- YOU KNOW I'LL
JUST SAY I THINK THIS WILL HAVE
A BIG IMPACT I THINK I HAVE A
VERY POSITIVE IMPACT. ON ON THE
PEOPLE WHO USE THE EQUIPMENT-
WHO WERE YOU KNOW SUFFERING
FROM THE NEGATIVE HEALTH.
CONSEQUENCES THAT THAT CENTER
STERN MENTIONED- AND THEN IT'LL
HELP IT'LL HELP YOU KNOW ALL
THE ENVIRONMENT AND HELP US
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND SMOG. CREATING EMISSIONS-
THAT THE CURRENT EQUIPMENT.
CREATES AND SO- I UNDERSTAND
THAT IT WILL BE A CHANGE IT'LL
BE A GRADUAL CHANGE- BECAUSE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO REPLACE
EVERYTHING RIGHT AWAY THE CAN
DO IT SLOWLY IS AS- INDIVIDUAL
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT BREAKDOWN-
BUT I THINK. THIS IS A FEATURE
THAT WE ALL KNOW WE NEED TO GO-
E. AND YEAH THIS IS JUST THE
BILL REALLY JUST SAYS TO CARB.
YOU HAVE TO CREATE THE
REGULATIONS BY A CERTAIN DATE
AND IT LEAVES IT UP TO CARVE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IS THE RIGHT
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS THE
RIGHT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY SIX IS
THE RIGHT YEAR. YOU KNOW THE
REGULATORS WILL THAT MAKE THAT
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION- BUT I
DO APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW.
THIS IS A CHANGE AND- THE KNOW
CHANGES ALL HARD. PERSEVERANCE
SAY THAT. AT LEAST IN MY OFFICE
I GET CALLS EVERY DAY ABOUT HOW
WE SEE THE LEGISLATURE GAVE THE
POWER TO SOME OTHER AGENCY THAT
TOOK IT AWAY FROM THERE FROM
THE LEGISLATORS AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
GIVES POWER TO THEIR BOARD TO
MAKE A DECISION THE SAME POWER
WE GAVE TO THE PARMA TOXIC
SUBSTANCE AND THE WATER BOARD
AND ALL THOSE PEOPLE THAT DON'T
DON'T HAVE TO STAND FOR
ELECTION. ARE GETTING THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE LOS
FURTHER OUT WE WON'T BE HERE
WE'LL PROBABLY MORE LIKELY BE
TURNED OUT AND THEN THOSE LAWS
ARE GOING TO FACT AND YOU KNOW
THE HISTORY GETS LOST AND THEN
WE END UP WITH. BUREAUCRATS
MAKING LAWS. THAT REALLY WILL
IMPACT OUR PEOPLE NOT ON GOOD
COMMON SENSE OF. THOSE RESULT
BE OPPOSING THIS I APPRECIATE
THAT JUST A QUICKLY NOTE THIS
LOT TO ISN'T THE ONE THAT GIVES
CARVE THE AUTHORITY THEY%
ALREADY HAVE THE AUTHORITY-
THIS THIS BILL WOULD SAY YOU'VE
GOT TO DO IT BY A CERTAIN TIME.
AND ALSO TRY TO FREE UP.
FUNDING BUT BUT BUT THE- LEAD
TO UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE
THE POINT YOU'RE MAKING. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- I WANT I
THINK THE AUTHOR AS WELL FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW WE
HAD A QUICK CHAT OVER THE
WEEKEND ABOUT THIS AND- OF THE
WAY THAT YOU'VE CRAFTED THE
BILL IN IN TERMS OF. BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE AIR BE DISCONCERTED SET
THAT RULE MAKING AND I KNOW
THAT'S IN PROGRESS- BOTH AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND EVEN IN OUR
BACKYARD SOUTH COAST A CANDY-
OF COURSE. I WILL ALWAYS
ADVOCATE FOR THE EQUITY
COMPONENT AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO THAT AS
WELL AND ENSURING THAT.
SPECIALLY ARE LATINO BUSINESS
OWNERS AND THIS IS BEEN SAID IN
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS- BUT THAT
THEY DON'T GET LEFT BEHIND IN
THIS CONVERSATION AND ALL MANY
CITIES AND LOCALITIES ARE
CREATING EVEN SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS- A ONE SHEET. IN BOTH
ENGLISH AND SPANISH BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT THEM TO FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE FALLING OFF OF A CLIFF
HERE THIS IS THEIR LIVELIHOOD
AS WELL AND I KNOW WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT- BUT- THEY NEED
TO ALSO UNDERSTAND TO SENATOR
STERN'S POINT. THE HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT THERE. CERTAINLY
UNDERTAKING. WHILE THEY'RE
BECOMING ENTREPRENEURIAL AND
THOSE HEALTH IMPACTS JUST LIKE
WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE ZERO
MISSION SPACE FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES MET MEDIUM HEAVY
DUTY IN THE PORT- ARE. ARE
SIGNIFICANT SOME OF US AND YOU
KNOW LONG BEACH AREA THE WEST
SIDE OF LONG BEACH. SOUTHEAST
L. A. ARE DEALING WITH DOUBLE
IMPACTS. BELIEVE THERE IS SUCH
A- THE GENERATORS ON TOP OF THE
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER AT
OUR PORTS. SO IT'S JUST A
COMPOUNDING OF ISSUES AND SO I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE GOT A LOT.
TO WORK ON HERE TO BE ABLE TO
JUST DRIVE THAT FORWARD- BUT WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT. HOPEFULLY
WORKING WITH LOCALS AS WELL NOT
TO BE AS PUNITIVE AS AS ON THE
FRONT END. BUT TO WORK WITH-
THE LOCALS AND WITH THESE- A
SMALL BUSINESSES TO GET US TO A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN ALL AGREE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER I AGREE A 100%
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT. THE
NEED FOR THE CARROTS THAT
CENTER DAHLE I WAS TALKING
ABOUT YEAH THAT THAT IS BECOME
MORE AND MORE APPARENT TO ME IS
THE BILL HAS MOVED ON AND- I AM
I AM. YOU'RE VERY FOCUSED ON
GETTING IT YOU KNOW. TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
INCENTIVES ASIAN PROGRAM TO
HELP WITH THAT TRANSITION. YOUR
POINT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE
HAVE TO MAKE IT. VERY CLEAR AND
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT
THAT OPPORTUNITY ONCE WE GET
THE FUNDING THAT THAT FUNDING
EXISTS THAT THEY QUALIFY FOR
IT- AND I HAVE A LOT OF-
JOINING CO AUTHORS WHO ARE.
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT
ISSUE AS WELL AND WILL NOT LET
ME- THE- DID SKATE BY IF THAT'S
NOT ADDRESSED SO- APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU. SARCASTIC GOOD
LUCK ON THE FUNDING PIECE I WAS
HAVING A CHAT WITH MY COLLEAGUE
OF REMINDING HIM OF TWO THREE
YEARS AGO WHEN THE SENATE HAD
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THE CAR
MORE YOUR PLAN AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE COULDN'T GET
TO A THREE WAY DEAL WITH THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE AND THE
GOVERNOR SO GLAD TO HEAR
LEGISLATION COMING IN FROM THE
OTHER HOUSE ON THIS THING I
THINK I MISUNDERSTOOD YOUR BILL
WHEN I INITIALLY LOOKED AT IT
AND- I REAL BECAUSE I WAS
CONCERNED THAT THERE WAS SOME
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE AIRPORT
AND LEGISLATION AND YOU KNOW WE
IN THE LAW WE DON'T LIKE WHEN.
PEOPLE ARE MAKING DECISIONS WE
DON'T WANT TO COME IN AND SAY
IT'S GOING T BE THIS WAY AND
ACTUALLY IS A FURTHER REVIEW OF
IT WE AS HAVE STAFF REPORT
POINTS OUT THE AIRPORT IS
DEALING WITH THIS RECORD THESE
REGULATIONS THERE INDICATING
AND THEY THE THEY'RE INDICATING
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO COME THIS
FALL AND COME UP WITH IT. IN
YOUR- BILL MARY STAT WITH
WHATEVER TIME WHEN THEY COME
INTO YOU THE ONLY HAMMER IF
THERE IS A HAMMERS SAID FINISH
THE REGULATIONS BY JULY FIRST.
NEXT YEAR IT IS THAT'S ALL WE
WANT IS WE WANT THIS THING TO
BE DONE AND WHAT THE
PROHIBITION IS ON THE SEWERS OR
THE COMMISSION. EVAPORATIVE
EMISSIONS THAT USING IT
LIMITATION YOU FOLKSTAKE CARE
THAT TECHNICAL STUFF AND THEN.
THE OTHER INCENTIVE HE SAID. WE
I WANT THIS TO HAPPEN ON JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WHICH
IS REALLY. THAT DIALOGUE
BETWEEN THIS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LASSEN COUNTY WAS SAYING IS
THAT WE ALREADY DELEGATED OR HE
DIDN'T SAY THAT YOU SAID THAT
THE WE DELEGATE THE AUTHORITY.
GRANTED THESE REGULATIONS BUT
NOW THE LEGISLATURE IS TRYING
TO GIVE SAYS SHAPE SOME SORT
OF. COURSE HERE IN SAYING IN
WOULD LIKE THESE THINGS TO
HAPPEN ON- THE TWENTY FIRST-
THE PIECE THAT'S NOT. TALKED
ABOUT. IS THAT THE CARL MOYER
AND THE SMALL BIT. BIT WHERE
YOU'RE- MAKING THE ASKING THE
AIRPORT TO MAKE WHEN THEY DO
THESE REGULATIONS TO MAKE THOSE
FUNDS AVAILABLE. TO COMMERCIAL.
FOR COMMERCIAL REBATES AND THAT
SORT OF BEEN SILENT HERE SO I
KNOW. OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH IS WORRIED ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN THIS BUSINESS
BECAUSE WE FOR WE'VE ALL HEARD
FROM THE OPPOSITION ON THIS.
BUT BUT- CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG THAT THAT THAT THIS IS
THIS IS SOME GUIDANCE HERE BUT
THIS IS THIS TRAINS LEFT THE
STATION ALREADY AT THE AIRPORT
AND THEY'RE GOING YOU JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE GOT WE
GOT THE RIGS ARE ON THIS STATE
CERTAIN AND THIS COULD TAKE
EFFECT ON THE STATE'S CERTAIN.
THAT'S RIGHT AND THEN YOUR
POINT ABOUT ABOUT HE DIED
DROWNING GUIDANCE TO CARBON.
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT- THAT PEOPLE
CAN GET REBATES OR INCENTIVES
FUNDING FOR IS LIKE YOU SAID
KIND OF THE QUIET BUT VERY
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THE BILL
SO THAT MORE- COMMERCIAL-
LANDSCAPING COMPANIES CAN
QUALIFY. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW AND
CAN QUALIFY FOR MORE A BROADER
RANGE OF EQUIPMENT- BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW IT'S VERY NARROW ON
THE COMMERCIAL SIDE ITS BROADER
ON THE RESIDENTIAL SIDE. AND
THAT'S WHY A LOT OF- EQUALITY
DISTRICTS UTILIZE RESIDENTIAL
REBATES BUT NOT SO MUCH
COMMERCIAL AND I THINK. WE NEED
TO FOCUS MORE ON THE
COMMERCIAL. TO BE HONEST. YEAH.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT I'M- CHECK YEAH
HI I WAS VERY NON MOVED. JUDGE
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'VE VERY WELL
HANDLED THANK YOU RESPECT AFTER
AYE VOTE. FIVE CONTROL THE CAR.
I REMEMBER EIGHT AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALAN. HI ALLEN AYE BATES. DALLY
DALLY NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
SKINNER STERN HI STERN AYE WHY
CASKEY HI ASKEY I. FORTY ONE
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR-
FOR A CENTER SKINNER AND CENTER
BASED ON THANK YOU I KNOW
YOU'RE ALSO GOING TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL'S AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. QUESTIONS
ON THIS. I AM ONLY NUMBER OF IT
WE DO HAVE- WE HAVE SUPPORT
WITNESSES SO. WE CAN DROP ON
THEM THANK YOU MISTER YOU READY.
CENTER YEP YEAH WE ABSOLUTELY
DID YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND CENTERS ON BEHALF
OF SOMEONE OVER GABRIEL I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK AND
THOUGHTFUL ASSISTANCE IN
CRAFTING MEANINGFUL MOMENTS TO
STRENGTHEN AND FURTHER REFINE
THIS BILL IS ONLY MEMBER
GABRIEL GLADLY ACCEPTS THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH WILL EMPOWER
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING. AND RESEARCH TO
IMPROVE THE SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA PLAN TO THAT STATE
AGENCIES CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AND EFFECTIVELY
TO ADDRESS OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
THE IMPACTS OF THE CLIMATE
CRISIS ARE BEING FELT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
AROUND THE WORLD LAST SUMMER
TEMPERATURES IN WOODLAND HILLS
AND SOMETHING OR GIVE ROLES
DISTRICT SURGED TO A INCREDIBLE
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DEGREES
THE HIGHEST READING EVER
RECORDED IN L. A. COUNTY.
ELEVATED TEMPERATURES EXPLOSIVE
WILDFIRES RISING SEA LEVELS AND
WORSENING DROUGHTS AND FLOODS
ARE GRIM REMINDERS OF OUR NEW
CLIMATE REALITY IN A CALL TO
ACTION WELL THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ENACTED FRAMEWORKS AND ENDORSE
VARIOUS POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
CALIFORNIA STILL LACKS
GOVERNANCE PRIORITIZATION AND
METRICS ON CRITICAL PRIORITY
ACTIONS AND TIMELINES TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE ADAPTATION
GOALS AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR ADDRESSES
THIS GAP BY TASKING THE
NATIONAL NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. IN THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH WITH
DEVELOPING TIMETABLES AND
METRICS THAT WILL HELP TO TRACK
PROGRESS AND FACILITATE TIMELY
CONCRETE ACTION TOWARD
ACHIEVING OUR CLIMATE GOALS
IT'S A DOING AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR ALSO WILL ELEVATE EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS BY IDENTIFYING
AND PROVIDING SPECIAL
PROTECTIONS FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND INDUSTRIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE TESTIFYING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR ARE READ ADDIS ON
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION. AND DIANA WINE AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CHAPTER THANK YOU AND ON
BEHALF OF A SUMMER GABRIEL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
LET'S FIRST FROM- DIANA WENT
OUT FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
FOLLOWED BY READ OUT THIS. THE
MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DIANA WINANT AND I'M
THE CHAIR OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CHAPTER OF THE CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT. I'M A REALITY
PROJECT'S MISSION IS TO
CATALYZE A GLOBAL SOLUTION TO
THE CLIMATE CRISIS BY MAKING
URGENT ACTION UNDER CENTER CITY
ACROSS EVERY SECTOR OF SOCIETY.
I AM HONORED TO BE HERE AND
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. THE
BILL REQUIRED THE STATE
AGENCIES TO COLLABORATIVE WE
ENGAGE WITH REGIONAL AND LOCAL
ENTITIES AND PORTABLE
COMMUNITIES. TO DEVELOP AND
COORDINATE STRATEGIC RESILIENCY
FRAMEWORK THAT WOULD ADDRESS
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
WARNER IS ONE OF THE MOST
CLIMATE CHALLENGE REGION IN
NORTH AMERICA IN THE LOS
ANGELES REGION SPECIFICALLY IT
IS EXPECTED TO WARM FOUR TO
FIVE DEGREES BY MID CENTURY AND
THE YEARLY NUMBER OF DAYS OVER
NINETY FIVE DEGREES IS
PROJECTED TO ALMOST QUADRUPLE
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
CLIMATE SCIENTISTS PREDICTED
THAT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO FOR TWENTY FIFTY SEA LEVEL
RISE ALONG THE CALIFORNIA COAST
FIVE TO TWENTY FOUR INCHES.
TIDES AND STORM SURGE CAN CAUSE
COASTAL FLOODING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY WHEN BIG
WEIGHT STORMS OCCURRING HIGH
TIDE. LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALSO
SUFFERS FROM SOME OF THE WORST
AIR POLLUTION IN THE COUNTRY
WHICH IS A PROBLEM WORSENED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. WATER
TEMPERATURES SPEED UP THE
CHEMICAL REACTIONS THAT CREATE
GROUND LEVEL OZONE THE MAIN
COMPONENT OF SMOG. GROUND LEVEL
OZONE IS GOING TO ASTHMA
BRONCHITIS HEART ATTACKS AND
PREMATURE DEATH. IT IS CRITICAL
THAT THE STATE TAKES ACTION ON
CLIMATE CHANGE A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMAN
GABRIEL WILL CREATE COORDINATED
GOVERNMENTAL ACTION. ON
CRITICAL PRIORITY ACTIONS AND
TIMELINES TO ACHIEVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I ENCOURAGE YOUR YES
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU LET'S
MEXICO TO READ ADDIS. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THEM THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN FOR
PRESENTING TODAY READ ADDRESS
ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION OUR FOCUS IS
BREAKING DOWN BARRIERS TO
NATURE THE COMMUNITIES WE WORK
AND- WE ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
DEAL WITH EQUITY PEOPLE AND
NATURE. HI MY COLLEAGUES IN
SUPPORT MADE OUT THE OVER
ARCHING ISSUES WITH THIS BILL
GOES FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WERE
IN SUPPORT TODAY ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE OF THE EQUITY
PROVISIONS AND THE INTEREST IN
TRYING TO HAVE THE STATE WORK
AND COORDINATE. WITH THE
REGION'S. SENATOR REID CAL CAN
WORK IN THE PAST ON I. CARTOONS
BEEN. I DON'T REALLY USEFUL AND
WE SEE HOW THAT CAN WORK BY
COMBINING HIGH COURT OPR
SAFEGUARDING PLAN AS YOUR STAFF
AND SENATOR STERN STAFFER
WORKED OUT YOU WERE IN CHARGE
PORT AND DANNY. BOB WE LIKE
WHERE THE DIRECTION OF THE
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING AND WE
ACTUALLY HOPE- THAT WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS AND OUR WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION. HAVE FELT
IT WILL I GET. TO THE GOVERNOR
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OKAY. LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINE SEE FOLKS
WANT TO WIN IN SUPPORT. OF FOR
AB THIRTEEN FOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW.
MY NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON NATALIE NINE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD LAN
TRUCK AND MANSION THAT COULD
COUNTY ALL IMPORTANT AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. MY NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PHIL MURPHY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTIONS NOR CAL IN
SOCAL CHAPTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JANET **** PORTRAIT
IF YOU THOUGHT AND BALLY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK. MY NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY FIVE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY
SHAKER SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ALEXANDER NOVICE FROM THE
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
A BI THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THANK
YOU. AND AT THIS TIME IF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU. ARE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES THAT ARE
SIGNED UP- TO OPPOSE THE BILL
WE ALSO DON'T HAVE ANY
RESTAURANT POSITION THE BILL-
AND- DOES ANYONE WANT TO
EXPRESS CONCERNS ON THE PHONE
LINES ABOUT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION A BABY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEY'RE ALL. GREAT WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. AT THIS
TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
MONEY Q. SO LET'S BRING THE
BILL BACK TO COMMITTEE I WANT
TO I DO CERTAINLY- REALLY WANT
TO GO. AND APPRECIATE THE-
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- HAVING
BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR I
LOVE THE IF YOU CAN GIVE A THAT
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY HAD WE HAD
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THE
BILL IS FOR AND I KNOW THAT
SENATE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
HAD SOME CONCERNS FINANCIALLY
AS WELL I WANT TO THINK THAT.
NOT TO RESOURCES STAFF AND OUR
STAFF AND THE AUTHOR STAFF ALL
WORKING TOGETHER TO- TO. YOU
KNOW TO DO IT WILL BASICALLY
TAKE WHAT I THINK WITH THAT
THAT IT'S COR- VERY LAUDABLE
AND IMPORTANT GOALS AT THE
HEART OF THE BILL- BUT- REFOCUS
THEM IN A WORKABLE WAY. AND-
AND REALLY WHAT WE ARE WITH MY
TOWARD CENTERING EQUITY I'M
USING THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE ATTY METRICS AND
TIMETABLES I'M SORRY THANK YOU
FOR EVERYBODY INVOLVED I LET'S
OPEN UP THE FLOOR TO QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS- CENTER CASKEY SO
I UNDERSTAND THE SEVEN.
THURMOND I HAVE TO ASK YOU THE
QUESTION SINCE YOU'RE
PRESENTING ON THIS SO THE
DEBATE. HAS BEEN THAT WHEN
SCHWARZENEGGER SET UP THE
CLIMATE ACTION TEAM HE NAMED IT
A NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCIES
THAT THAT'S THIRTEEN YEARS AGO
WHAT'S EVOLVED IS THAT WE'VE
SEEN THAT- P. R. N. AND THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH CANCEL MADE TO
A BETTER JOB AT AT STRATEGIC
RESILIENCY PLANNING AND
RECOMMENDATION AND IDENTIFYING
WHAT NEEDS TO OCCUR ON THE
GROUND. THE BILL HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED. DELEGATED THAT
AUTHORITY TO THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNSEL NINE UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'RE GOING TO DIRECT. DID
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
WHICH IN MY MIND IS THE BETTER
PLACE FOR THIS THING TO LAND
RIGHT TO IT AS PART OF THE
UPDATES TO THE SAFEGUARDING.
CALIFORNIA SUIT SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA. IS A REPORT SO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES WORKS WITH
ALL THE AGENCIES GETS THE STUFF
GETS WHAT CALTRANS TO AN EDITOR
THAT I. DOES THE FIFTY SUSSMAN
IF WE ALLOCATE SOME MONEY BUT
THAT'S TO BE DETERMINED LATER
BUT SO THE QUESTION IS ALL THE
OTHER WORK YOU KNOW IT'S ONE
THING READING THE REPORT BUT
THE STRATEGIES TO BE DOING THAT.
IS THAT ARE WE GIVING THE
DIRECTIONS TO THE OPR. CAN HAVE
IT MAKE SURE THE REPORTERS THAN
WHAT THE RESOURCE AGENCY-
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT REQUIRING
THIS RETREAT YOU GULF COUNCIL
TO DEVELOP IT. CAN I. I SEE THE
STAFF REPORT BUT THEY OBVIOUSLY
DON'T SEE A MOCK UP BUT THAT
WOULD BE MY- THE HELPFULL
RECOMMENDATIONS. BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE CLIMATE PEOPLE. SO
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DEFERRED TO THE CHAIR IS THAT
IS THAT THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHORING CULT IN CONSULTATION
OF DETERMINE THAT OPR IS THE
BEST AGENCY TO TAKE CAN LEAD
THIS PROCESS SINCE YOU'RE THE
PROCESS- AND IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR THEIR
WAITING INPUT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- ON THIS
ISSUE AS WELL BUT THAT'S
CURRENTLY WHERE WE STAND I HOPE
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTIONS AND
IT DOES IT DOES THAT AND MORE.
BEAUTIFUL THANK ARE GONNA WALK
OUT THEN. OKAY ALL RIGHT- OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS WITH SOMEONE
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL. MOVED BY
CENTER SKINNER- DECEMBER YOU
MAKE MAY- CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON BEHALF
OF US IN THE NUMBER GABRIEL
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OKAY ACAPULCO'S COLOR ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN. HI ALAN
I'D BATES. DALLI DALLI NO
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER
GAVE REAL BILL SKINNER AYE
STERN GABRIEL DR WHITE COUNTY
HIGH ASKEY I HAVE TO MOVE TO A-
FIVE TO ONE SIDE. OKAY I THANK
YOU LET'S ENTERTAIN A MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. IT'S
REMOVED BY CENTER CONSOLIDATES-
THE CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS FIVE AND SEVEN ALLEN HI
ALLEN I BATES BATES BY TALLYING.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE WHY
CASKEY BY CAL SKI I'VE- SIX TWO
ZERO OKAY IT'S SIX ZERO THAT
OPEN FOR CENTER DOLLY TO ADD
ON. OKAY LET'S A LET'S LIST THE
CALLS ON THE VARIOUS BILLS
LET'S START WITH THE BE
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE THAT'S
MORE CITIES CLIMATE CRISIS
ACTORS BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF
THE ITEM NUMBER. I'M SORRY YES.
YES IT IS GONNA BE AMENDED-
HE'S MADE EASY SET THE NUMBER
OF MNCS COMMITTED TO ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS. OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
WORK. YET TO GO ON THAT DEAL
AND- IT'S ALSO GOING TO
PREPARATIONS. WITH THE STAFF IS.
AROUND YEAH OR THE YES WE HAVE
A- WE THE SO WE HAVEN'T LANDED-
SOME EXACT WARNING ON ON CARBON
CAPTURE- WE'VE HE'S A GREETING
CONCEPTS- WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
HIM OR SOMETHING AND ENGAGE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- TODAY YOU
KNOW HE CERTAINLY IS A GREEN
CONCEPT TO ACCEPTING LANGUAGE
THAT DOESN'T PRECLUDE CARBON
CAPTURE AS A- AS A POTENTIAL
MEDICARE- BUT THERE'S STILL
SOME. WORK TO BE DONE ON ON THE
LANGUAGE. THE I REALIZE WE'RE
JUST CALLING ROLE NOW SO BUT
HI. I'M A CO AUTHOR AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING IT IN MY STAFF
HAS BEEN WORKING ON THAT
QUESTION OF HOW TO FIX THAT
DEFINITION TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS AND SO I JUST WANT TO
PUT ON THE RECORD THAT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING IT OF COURSE WITH
COMMITTEES MOMENTS BUT ALSO
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL. CALM DOWN.
MAKE THOSE AT ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES YEAH ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTOOD. UNDERSTOOD OKAY
LET'S LIFT ACOSTA NOW AND SO
YES THIS IS LET'S START WITH
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. I AM
NUMBER ONE AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MARTUCCI. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTERS TO
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
AT BATES NO. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I SKINNER PIPE SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN HI. FIVE TWO TWO
FIVE TWO WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
ON THAT ITEM LET'S NOW GO TO
ITEM TWO IN YOUR AGENDAS
MEMBERS THIS IS SCIENCE. TOUCH
VERNE BOERNER HORVATH AB ONE
SEVENTEEN. CONTEMPLATES CHOLERA
AND A NUMBER TO AB ONE
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FORKNER HARBATH. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTERS THREE
TO ZERO WITH THE- CHAIR VOTING
AYE BATES. BATES NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN I. OKAY LET'S CALL
THE ROLL ON THAT ITEM LET'S GO
NEXT TO YOU THREE OF US AB.
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE. ADAM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE VOTE IS THREE TWO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE BATES.
BATES NOT VOTING DALLYING
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE STERN
STERN HI. IT'S FIVE TWO ONE
EIGHT FIVE TO ONE LET'S NOW GO
TO AB SIXTY THIS IS ON A BERKS
BILL I ITEM OR FOR. I REMEMBER
IT FOR A. B. SIX EIGHTY BY
SOMEBODY MEMBER BURKE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE VOTERS FORTY ZERO WITH
CHAIR MONNING AYE. BATES BATES
NODE DALY. SKINNER SKINNER I'D-
IT'S FIVE TWO ONE FIVE TWO ONE
GREAT THAT BILL IS OUT WILL
NEXT GO TO. I DON'T SIX AB NINE
FIFTY WARD. I NUMBER SIX AB
NINE FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS FOUR
TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE BATES. BATES NO SKINNER.
SKINNER I. IT'S FIVE TWO TWO
FIVE EIGHT TWO OKAY WE WILL
CLOSER ON THAT AT THOSE OUTLETS
NOW I BELIEVE THE BERMAN BILL
DIFFERENT ON THAT. FIRST TRY
THAT AGAIN THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
ANYONE OUTSTANDING. YES ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST. BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
VOTERS FOUR TO ONE BATES. WELL
BATES NOW SKINNER SKINNER I.
THAT'S FIVE TWO TWO OKAY FIVE
TO THE BILL IS OUT ON FINALLY
THE GAME REAL BILL THIS IS-
ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHT AT AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. I
REMEMBER NINE AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND TO
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SUPPOSED FIVE TO
ONE. THE CHAIR VOTING I'D
BATES. BATES NO. FIVE TWO FIVE
ZERO OKAY THAT BILL THAT AS
WELL I'M DID SENATOR DOLLY ONE
OF ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. I
ASSUME YOU JUST SKIPPED OUT.
COULD SOMEONE CALL STAFF AND
JUST DOUBLE CHECK AS TO WHERE
HE IS ON THAT IF YOU WANT TO
VOTE FOR THE CAN SECOND ARE THE
WAYS WILL AND- ADJOURNED BUT- I
WILL CERTAINLY. BE HAPPY TO
STAY FOR A COUPLE EXTRA MINUTES
FOR HIM TO COME BACK YOU MAY
NOT HAVE REMEMBERED IT. WE
HADN'T YET THIRD THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MOTION. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YEAH MUCH YOU KNOW I
HAD TO LEAVE AND I. I WAS
FRIDAY I DIVED. YEAH. I'M AS
SOMEONE CALLED CENTER DOLLARS
OFFICE WHERE THEY SAY. SO HE'S
COMING IN I CALLED IN. ARE THEY
DOING OKAY. WOULD SOMEONE MIND-
OKAY FOR IT. THIS.
WHAT. WE
JUST WENT THROUGH ON THE
CONSENT HONOR I THINK I YOU
KNOW IT'S AYE THAT'S THE ONLY
THING I THINK YEAH I THINK
EVERYTHING ELSE HE I THINK HE
JUST FORGOT THAT- HE HAD VOTED
ON. WE HAVE. I ALSO HAVE AN-
EXCITING. YEAH.
UHHUH UHHUH.
REPUBLICAN. EVERYTHING. OKAY
AND I HAD A LITTLE. YEAH YEAH.
YEAH. ONLY DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM.
YEAH.
LET'S DO THIS- LET'S
REOPEN THE RULES ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSULTANT PLEASE
COLOR ITEMS NUMBER FIVE AND
SEVEN DALY. NOW I AT SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS PASSED I BELIEVE THE REST OF
US ARE FINAL SO LET'S NOW
ADJOURN THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE PHARMACOLOGY ME.